yeah so apparently uh they're gonna
arrest Trump tomorrow and a lot of
people don't believe it a lot of people
are claiming it's not true despite the
fact that Trump himself tweeted it but
Trump may have been tweeting it based
off news reports so we really don't know
for sure other than in New York they are
starting to put barricades around the
Manhattan DA's uh the district Manhattan
district court so a lot of people are
assuming that these barricades imply
they're intending to issue an indictment
for Donald Trump for the arrest which
would require extradition likely from
Florida but this would result in massive
protests we will see we don't know but
the New York Times reporting outright
that the New York authorities are
preparing for the unprecedented arrest
of an ex-president oh boy New York tries
to arrest a former president who's the
current front-runner Florida would have
to extradine but Rhonda Santos is
basically saying we're not getting
involved so we'll see what happens some
people what will happen some people are
saying that isn't any of the he doesn't
have the authority to deny it but he
might just say F off I'm not getting
involved anyway so he may not
necessarily say screw off I won't do it
he might just be like hey man don't look
at me and passively but if Ron DeSantis
allows the indictment of Donald Trump
there is no way DeSantis will get
anywhere near the presidency and if
Donald Trump gets arrested it's probably
going to dramatically help his
presidency oh it's okay instead of just
opining already we'll get into this
before we do head over to timcast.com
and click that join us button to become
a member and support our work you'll see
right there on the left menu side
when you click that button you can then
sign up to become a 10 a month member
and get access to the uncensored live
after show Monday through Thursday we
put those up around 10 10 p.m and
there's something else now we have a
Discord server where you can hang out
and chat There are rules because the
goal of the Discord is to have more
academic conversation around our views
what's going on in the news and a way
that we can connect with you which means
if we just said hey it's a free speech
thing say whatever you want we get Ben
two seconds and it would serve nobody so
we'll do what we can to create that path
so that you can chat with us we can hear
stories that you think that you're
interested in that maybe we'll want to
talk about like you say hey look at the
store say oh that's really good and more
importantly if you become a 25 a month
member for the first time you instantly
get access to the VIP lounge which
allows you to submit call-in questions
for the after show and anyone who's been
a member for at least six months has
instant access as well
I think I'm pretty sure if you're a 25
member 25 per month member after six
months you could just drop down to 10
bucks we're just trying to create a way
to keep out the weirdos so there's a pay
gate and a Time gate I wish there was an
easier way to do it but that's the best
we can do becoming a member uh just
helps us run the company and then for uh
anybody who's really interested there's
an elite club room with only a handful
of people in it where we'll probably
have crew people like me Ian Phil other
timcast.com employees hanging out that's
the elite club it's 100 bucks a month
we're intending to make that something
bigger that would be tied to physical
spaces as well so if you don't want to
sign up just yet for it I understand but
we're trying to make some kind of Social
Club thing where we can you know people
can pitch ideas and work with each other
so that we can expand out
entrepreneurial I don't know
entrepreneurship if you're somebody
who's trying to get involved with a
bunch of other people sit down have
those meetings with a physical location
there's a lot coming in that regard but
become a member to support our work
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends it's the best way to
help joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is James klug how
you doing thanks for having me really
appreciate it you guys I am a YouTuber
at James klug on YouTube we specialize
in man on Street videos and also you
guys huge fan of the show thanks for
having me absolutely there you go well
thanks for coming it should be fun we
got Shane Cashman he's got a book
apparently what's up guys yeah I have
the uh the new Tales from the inverted
World Volume 2 book this is my story of
uh going down to Washington Georgia
looking for the Confederate gold finding
some uh demon-possessed people talking
to uh people who talk to ghosts looking
at UFOs aiming aiming AR-15s at UFOs
over the tree line good stuff sounds
very dangerous and the Guidestones and
my side quest of trying to figure out
who uh bombed the Guidestones oh yeah
yeah and we forgot to take the Irish
flag off the wall that works I'm Irish
so yeah I'll take it they uh we were
studying people with having um exorcisms
and things and some people I think Carol
mentioned that it may be people that are
having like epileptic fits but they
entry before they knew what epilepsy was
and then they'd start screaming and then
they'd be like oh my God there's like a
demon inside but I don't know did you I
I think for different people they have
different ways of interpreting it I
think I met some people who were uh
filled with something that I can't
believe it's in the book yeah nice
branding by the way I'm Ian cross on
everybody what's happening hey Serge yo
and I am search.com what's up guys hope
you're well
for this just before we get started some
people are saying they tried to sign up
for the Discord they're having issues if
you do ever have any issues email
members at timcast.com we'll get it
sorted for you I think there's what like
1500 people hanging out in the Discord
chatting all right now and I think about
a thousand plus are already in the VIP
lounge chat simply because they've been
members for long enough so hang out man
um we got it set up we're we are trying
to figure out like if you have a
thousand people how do we get someone to
call in because it still means you're a
one in one thousand chance you know if
50 people submit a question only one
person is going to get in so maybe we'll
do like two or three questions per day
but uh we'll try our best we'll try our
best anyway let's jump into this first
story from the New York Times New York
authorities prepare for unprecedented
arrest of an ex-president ahead of a
likely indictment law enforcement
officials are making security plans and
some of Donald J Trump supporters signal
that they intend to protest signal
Donald Trump called for them to protest
here's the video
Robert Costa said steel barricades
arriving outside Manhattan Criminal
Court okay I said District quarter
correct District Court earlier
correction criminal court and uh they're
getting ready for it
I do not believe that they would put up
oh wow he's got a lot of videos of this
holy crap I don't believe they would do
this unless they actually were planning
to indict Trump
because if they don't indict him there'd
be no protest right nothing would happen
this is where I saw like when I was
deciding if it like you know if it's
going to happen tomorrow or not that was
a big indicator do you guys see what uh
MSNBC said when it came to Trump's calls
for for protest they're saying you know
calling for another January 6th yeah
calling for people to pick up arms what
that's that's the way that they're
interpreting it it's like to pick up
arms yeah yeah pick up arms and or
calling for violence easy that's that's
what it is now yeah so just like it's
just like what they how they interpreted
January 6. like when they hear certain
words like we're gonna fight for our
country they take it and make it the
most vicious interpretation oh YouTube
does the same thing all the time I gotta
tell people like if they want to give
you a strike and you say something you
got to fight for your red like whoa oh
wow he has to call for violence these
insane standards that they hold for the
right it's it's so comical too like 2020
the Riots of 2020. they would do
everything that they could to basically
work it down if a super violent Riot
they would work it down to just being oh
it's just some people there's like a
whole parking lot on fire and that's the
standard that the police station was
burning down in the like fiery but
mostly peaceful that's where the meme
comes from like in Portland at the Marco
Hatfield federal courthouse trying to
burn down the courthouse with federal
agents inside and they're still not
reporting on it all Trump has to say is
hey go protests and that's a call for
for Action a call for violence I didn't
hear his call but what was it like if he
gets arrested he wants people on the
street he's a protest no I said protest
we need to take our country back which
they also interpret as right it's so
vague like should he be more specific
like be here at this time protest
illegal uh or or unjust arrests of
presidents and things like that I want
to read this real quick sorry uh this is
from The New York Times because there's
interesting framing here they say if
Donald Trump is indicted by a Manhattan
grand jury in the days ahead for his
role in a hush money payment to a porn
star the former president of the United
States of America will be read the
standard Miranda warning he will be told
that he has the right to remain silent
and the right to an attorney these are
among the routine steps for felony
arrests in New York but the unpreced the
rest of a former commander-in-chief one
who's devoted supporters once staged a
violent attack on the capitol will be
anything but routine let me uh pause
there for a minute is Trump being
charged with a felony I don't know my
understanding is a misdemeanor if guilty
they're seeing that as a misdemeanor and
that's what two years that they can go
after that after the Well there must be
a mistake crime that they're talking
about let me let me statute of
limitations is like two years in New
York state for a uh misdemeanor five
years for a felony but they're trying to
tie it to campaign malfeasance Finance
malfeasance to take it off the past the
uh that's how they're trying to extend
it past that five years even because
we're talking about a D.A that's looking
at something that's uh typically if if
guilty maybe a misdemeanor at best but
they're trying to go for not not only a
felony but they're trying to go for a
felony past they are trying to be
charged with the felony yeah that's my
point because they said a routine step
for felony arrests is a clever wording
trick to make it seem like he's being
charged with a felony if he isn't you
see what I mean yeah like if I were to
say something like I am going to arrest
James here then I will read him as
Miranda writes which is normal in felony
arrests it's like
you the reader then thinks you committed
a felony when it could be like you were
jaywalking and I'm giving you a citation
or something right I mean they just put
the word there so it goes in your brain
exactly you assume that's what it means
no It's Tricky word play it assumes
guilt right away when did this uh
supposed bribe is that what it is for
Stormy Daniels hush money when did it
get paid uh 2016 before the election
that's what they're that's what they're
uh they were talking about I guess it
happened like the action that they're
all talking about happened they were
saying 2006 and then 2016 this hush
money more of like a NDA hush money is
is right people usually say that for an
NDA hush money I don't think so I think
hush money is like when you commit a
crime you know what I mean like if if
someone catches you committing a crime
and you're like I'll give you money if
you don't say anything right hush funny
this is just an ambitious this is like
they hooked up and he's like but don't
tell anybody and I'll and what we come
to an agreement on non-disclosure it's
like it's like a contract right it's
like I'll give you X money in exchange
for X Behavior I don't know if if
there's any how is that illegal well and
a lot of people were also talking about
it possibly being some sort of like
nuisance or hopefully that's the right
phrase payment because 130 000 when
you're trying to win an election if they
were actually oh right for that purpose
right if it was for uh that purpose that
they're arguing 130 000 to a billionaire
seems a little bit low doesn't it she
was going to write a book or something
was the case like if it was the case if
he if he cheated on her or whatever if
he was trying to keep that quiet I
honestly I think they pay more than that
I think it's all nonsense you know if
they can arrest him for this we should
be able to arrest every president right
now look at the tar read allegations
against Joe Biden you've got to look at
the hunter Biden now
so the allegation against Trump is that
he gave some chicky banged money so she
wouldn't talk about it the allegation
against Joe Biden as he slammed Roman up
against the wall and forced himself on
her capital in the in the capital now
I'll be uh to be fair it was 30 years
ago you're going to be hard-pressed to
find any evidence of this the same thing
with talk with uh
blasey Ford and Kavanaugh although that
one lacks any credibility so much so
they had to keep calling it a credible
what do they call it a credible
accusation or something yeah incredibly
accused and it was like you're saying
that because it's not like you're you're
saying it over and over again because
the people who listen to you and follow
you are dumb as a box of rocks right
right and you need them to repeat it
because it has nothing credible about a
lady 30 years later lying about
everything and then accusing some like
Boy Scout of being a gang rapist yeah
bringing absolutely zero evidence and
everyone in his life was like oh he's a
great guy at that time like I don't know
she's like and then that other lady was
like he would line up outside of rooms
and the men would all gang bang women
and it's like bro if that happened it
would be like the cover of a newspaper
it'd be the biggest scandal in the
college's history for sure never
happened for sure the reason that
presidents tend to Pardon past
presidents when they get out of office
is because you want to avoid this
kicking the ball like what will happen
is if Trump really gets persecuted and
arrested then when Biden gets out of
office and another Administration comes
in they very likely will arrest Biden
for the same kind of crap and then
you'll have a cycle of arrests and
political persecution which devolves
into Anarchy Ford pardon Nixon right
yeah and the long National nightmare is
a way to try to bridge the gap in all
the division and you know chaos that was
going on in the country and I don't
think that's something that would happen
in the current political climate where
like Biden's going to Pardon anybody I
don't know he might because we talked
about this before but the first thing
I'll say Ian is Trump is being
persecuted if he's prosecuted is
something entirely different they've
been persecuting Trump for a long time
just coming after him for anything for
any reason because they hate him because
they're a zombie cult
you know there you go well also I think
it's important to kind of explain what's
going on here with the district attorney
right they've looked into this uh quote
hush money multiple times you this is I
believe the third go at this every other
time from much higher courts they're
saying okay well there's not really
enough to to charge Trump for anything
here now we have a very very Progressive
Soros D.A in Manhattan that's just
saying okay we'll give it a shot I'm
sure if I get them in front of a or if I
present this in front of a grand jury we
got a good shot at it you get them get
them subpoenaed and force them in a
criminal trial to testify and we'll get
him on something but this is them of
perjury or something for for this D.A he
has a a record of of downgrading charges
they're they're not uh they're not
Prosecuting what is it prostitution
right now they're not Prosecuting for
resisting arrest or any of that going on
he's a very Progressive D.A that that is
super soft on crime but for this he's
like he's going as hard as possible on a
quote crime that if it were to be the
case it would be six years a
six-year-old misdemeanor but I've I
think Biden might actually pardon Trump
well let me let me let me clarify these
are State charges Biden cannot pardon
Trump for State charges but I think in
the event of if there was a federal case
Biden does have a good incentive to
Pardon Trump for the Optics of we don't
play the games that Donald Trump does
when he says I am instructing the doj to
cease this activity you know we're a
nation of Law and Order blah blah at the
same time he might play the organization
of Law and Order therefore he must be
charged but I think there's a
possibility in a federal event that
Biden would be like I'm the bigger man
look at me I think there's a lot of
people who would reject that to who like
Biden and who hate Trump so much that if
he were to Pardon Trump they would see
that as a weak thing for their side I
yeah this is a group of people that that
don't care they want to see him behind
bars are zombies bloodthirsty right kind
of yeah but I don't know if you call I
don't know if you call them bloodthirsty
right they might not know they are
because they're brainless is what you're
saying but they are after blood
regardless it's an interesting question
like
vampires are bloodthirsty quite
literally right and so when we refer to
someone as a vampire it's like a
corporate CEO who's like you know maybe
they're like they're running a big drug
company that's getting guaranteed
contracts to push some kind of
experimental drug in the population we'd
call that person a vampire as like an
insult a zombie I don't know if you'd
call bloodthirsty you just call
like there's no brain there to have that
it's just it's just chaos and
destruction yeah so we just call them
zombies right zombies don't still need
to eat I don't think they can just stand
there for like a thousand it depends
which you zombie Universe
you know are these the running zombies
which kind of zombies we got here
they're the voting zombies for sure uh
but I don't know what we need to do is
you got to starve the zombies out by
turning off all social media for like a
month and then just watch them all spin
around confused not knowing who they're
supposed to pretend to be yeah I think
it'd be fun is it irreversible damage
though I don't know if turning it off
for a month we'll even fix it
like a month later there's just people
standing in the middle of the street
their eyes are white and they're just
like not moving it's like well there's
nothing there anymore it's like when
Adam and Eve realize they were human for
the first time and that they were naked
in a garden that was what would happen
to the zombies they'd be like oh yeah
you're you and I'm me they're realizing
that they can like think critically by
themselves without being told what to do
I will say I think I think from my
personal experience I think that the
left is author enough right now to where
they they they're just bloodthirsty when
it comes to Donald Trump they don't care
what the consequences are of locking
them up for something that's completely
absurd it's it's it's obviously
political persecution right obviously
it's obviously political persecution
persecution but I don't think they care
at all and I don't even think that they
care like I don't think they're thinking
far enough ahead to even see this being
uh a major help to Donald Trump in his
campaign he's already raising money
using this to raise money right now this
is going to be the biggest thing for his
campaign oh yeah if you think that the
energy behind Donald Trump's campaign in
2016 was big this is this is what we're
seeing right now in the US that we're
living in today and what we're seeing
right now with this political
persecution this is ten times worse than
when he was elected let me play this uh
Trump truth Donald Trump posted this
today at 307.
effectively accusing Alvin Bragg of I I
guess abusing a woman we'll put it that
way let's play the ad for George Soros
funded Democrat Alvin Bragg is known as
the worst da in the country his soft on
crime policies have Unleashed violent
criminals on innocent citizens and turn
New York City into a hellscape of crime
drugs and Chaos however Alvin Bragg's
crimes against the people of New York
may just be the tip of the iceberg
before Bragg's election it was revealed
that Soros cut off five hundred thousand
dollars in funds to Bragg's campaign
it was reported that there were
disturbing allegations leveled against
Sprague by an unnamed woman there was no
investigation into the victim's charges
by the Manhattan DA's office and Alvin
Bragg is yet to be charged I'm the only
thing standing between the American
dream and total Anarchy Madness and
chaos and that's what it is I'm
representing you I'm just here
always remember they are coming after me
because I am fighting for you that's
what's happening
so he's already using this to campaign
right but um I hate to do it but he's
making me defend Alvin Bragg all right
here here's the issue right Alvin Bragg
was not a was not formally Accused by
anybody who we know an unnamed woman is
the story and
there were no charges what does that say
it says he didn't do anything that's it
if some unnamed Anonymous woman accused
him of doing something and there were no
charges am I going to be a lie oh man
you know I gotta go for that I got that
Donald Trump's a bad guy no I'm not
playing that game I don't like brag I
don't like Soros funded Diaz I think
they're awful I think this guy's
destroying New York City
well I think they have enough ammunition
against him to not even bring that up I
think it I think just takes away from
how bad he is as a D.A and by the way
probably the worst da in the country is
Phillies I forgot his uh I forgot the
name of the Philly person but I mean
Philadelphia Is A Wasteland A Wasteland
right yeah those videos but but I think
that they had they have more than enough
ammunition on Bragg to just completely
ignore all those distractions right
there I think that takes away from how
bad of a job he's already doing as
district attorney is this Larry krasner
Philadelphia yeah that's a that's
another sword that's like a top Soros
one I believe okay Soros is a vampire
yeah I think I think a good analogy for
that guy he's an evil evil oh guys
he's the definition of evil I mean he's
like evil as they come he thinks he's
good that's what's weird yeah sure I
don't think he thinks he's good
no there there are a lot of people that
I think they they think they're good and
there are a lot of people that will play
the philosophical game of like there's
such thing as good or evil there's the
actions blah blah I don't care
like I get it everybody thinks it's a
hero of their own story but
uh George Soros is an evil guy well he
spends tens of millions of dollars
electing district attorneys in in the
most liberal District Attorneys uh in
the United States that are letting
criminals back on the streets liberal is
the correct word left us yeah sorry
you're right about that but I'm not
liberal at all but I don't think I don't
think leftist is either he's funding
he's funding Joker acolytes he's he's
funding uh someone actually uh commented
in early in one of my earlier segments I
said what these DA's are doing is like
the Joker releasing all the bad guys
from Arkham Asylum someone mentioned
Bane did that uh Bane in Batman releases
all of the criminals into the city I
think that was uh the movie though
pretty sure it's the Joker that breaks
everybody out of Arkham Asylum in the
comics either way comic book villainy
these D these these these Soros Diaz are
comic book villains who are unleashing
crime into all of these cities it's like
Lex Luthor level stuff who is using
conditions of power who was in charge of
releasing all the prisoners from prisons
uh when kovid started with lockdowns
when they were telling us for breaking
lockdown they were literally all doing
what they're doing in California too
yeah that's when I started feeling like
America had turned into Arkham when
everyone's just getting told they can
leave the prisons but then if you don't
mask up or do whatever they will arrest
you and put you in jail they want you to
wear a mask in a store now I don't know
the salon owner in Texas who got
arrested and I think Abbott it was
Abbott or someone pointed out you're
arresting this woman because she opened
her Salon while releasing violent
criminals because of coveted policies
what is going on the lady who was
telling stuff on Facebook live and they
came to restore well the most shocking
thing too is a lot of people aren't
capable of like processing the whole job
of a district attorney so it's kind of
this like in invisible Enemy Within
cities what happens is they let all
these bad guys out these these violent
criminals back on the street they commit
crimes crime crime rates Skyrocket and
then it gives Democrats another
Boogeyman that's not the district
attorney they focus on guns and taking
away more gun rights they leverage those
high crime statistics to strip more of
your rights away instead of focusing on
the just garbage district attorneys in
these in these uh cities I was regarding
this video that Trump put out we just
listened to it I don't like that he's
going at he's that he does the
personality like oh I got attacked I'm
gonna attack the guy that attacked me I
want to I want to do personal attacks
and also he sounded tired man I just
listened to this Biden video of him uh
vetoing the Senate you know the the
Congressional bill that they're trying
to pass and Biden sounds like this when
he's talking like he's so old withered
and tired and now Trump sounds just
tired these guys we need new blood this
is just yeah is you're so silly in a
while is he 76 right now Trump I think
so yes yes I agree but I think you know
Trump's got to finish that character Arc
he's got to finish what he's what he
came here to do 76. he's the front
runner for a reason he's the story is
not over yet we are on you know that
we're nearing the final chapters but we
are still not at the end of the book
I hope so because I I voted from the
last for 2020 but the pardoning thing
was one of the things that really
bothered me well the way the way he went
out with the pardoning you know who we
pardon Julia
pretty weak and pardon the j6ers right
he could have got those guys out of
prison right and and I'm not talking
like if someone committed to violent
crime charge arrest them that's fine
yeah but some of these people were
sitting in for you know six months or
even years some people are still there
passing right and misdemeanor I I have
actually a a guy that I know um he went
in there uh just reporter he's been
casual reporter
basically a registered Democrat I think
his whole life not even not a hardcore
political guy either just kind of
standard you know California guy
Democrat and uh he went in there with a
DSLR camera around his neck non-violent
crime going to prison for four years
wait what going to prison for four years
not he his problem was is he was an
independent journalist and uh photo like
Photo journalist and um I don't believe
he had like a totally legit press pass
but yeah I mean you're trying to at
worst you're talking what is that a
trespassing charge but what they do with
these people they're making an example
out of them and they're in their are
pinning them with obstruction of an
official proceeding and getting them
with these insane charges that like if
you look at this guy for one second
you're like he's not obstructing
anything literally went in there with a
camera to go document what was happening
on January 6th yeah well they went to
prison for there was that uh that John
Sullivan guy whatever his name was
exactly I was thinking he he was in
there filming and documenting and they
got him as well and he was instigating
on some of those videos he was saying
yeah did he break a window or something
he was instigating in a lot of in a lot
of those videos and he sold that footage
to a lot of a lot of corporate media
places CNN and was on those places as
like a talking head you know and then it
came out that he may be a bad actor you
know no one knows they said he was
antifa maybe well then all these
different things yeah he wasn't radical
yeah it was I believe he was but they
will say he wasn't can you do a thing
where if you're gonna pardon because I
think there's a lot of confusion of who
did what so rather than be like I'm
gonna pardon these 40 of these people
because you still don't know who did
what can you say I'm gonna pardon every
instance of this crime between the hours
of 1pm and 9 pm in this place and then
later when we find out who was involved
in that particular I'm going to Pardon
all the trespassing violations so then
later as it comes out like who did what
every time a trespassing violation comes
out it gets tossed is that a potential
way to Pardon crimes
I have no idea all all that matters is
they're making example out of these
Trump had a couple weeks left and he
could have been like nope you're get him
out
what a drop of the ball for leadership I
agree with you I I would say I I look at
these j6ers the same way I look at Alex
Jones and a few of the others when it
came to testing the waters with
censorship in America you know I really
look at these j6ers as testing the
waters when it came to uh political
persecution in the United States and
look what they're doing now yeah look at
look how far they're about to go like
actually uh going after Donald Trump and
for some BS you know you made a good
point earlier before we recording about
how this is like the image of this will
be so explosive just the purple oh
they're literally doing it just for that
and it'll be for both sides that image
yeah they're going to use it on on the
left is like look at this we've
destroyed this monster this Boogeyman
we've created on corporate media and
then the Trump side will be like we're
gonna put it on shirts and sell it yeah
Nelson Mandela basically I don't see a
way that it doesn't backfire I I see
this as being I mean you know you don't
want to be like indicted that's awful
but but I see it's amazing for Trump's
campaign and Trump honestly it's going
to be like that Meme of Kyle Rittenhouse
and Greta tunberg where it says compare
you know our 17 year old with their 17
year old tells you everything you need
to know and the left and the right share
the meaning the exact same ways right to
the left they're like wow credit tunberg
ooh Kyle on the right's like ooh Greta
wow Kyle but it's the same image it
exemplifies what Scott Adams was saying
about the same screen with two different
movies on at the same it's nuts yes so
we're going to see a photo of trump
being arrested and the left is going to
share and be like oh this proves it and
the right's gonna share it like oh this
proves it I guess it sounds like an nft
waiting to be made right and I guess to
clarify what I just said uh fantastic
for Trump when it comes to raising money
to getting his base you know uh
re-energized awful for the country yeah
awful yes because if you're a Democrat
amazing for Law and Order and for our
democracy and if you're a trump
supporter Republican it's amazing for
his campaign and chance for re-election
and then all it's doing is pushing
everybody into hyper tribalization man
when I was like 10 I I learned about
Nelson Mandela was like in the late 80s
and he was in jail or just got let out
of jail and I asked my dad like why was
he in jail he was a political prisoner
and I was like what what does that mean
what did he do wrong and he's like no no
it just means that the government didn't
like him and I was like 10 or 11 when I
learned that they could do that I was
like what they can just put you in jail
if they don't like well imagine being
born in any other part of the world or
at any other time
I don't like that guy and they cut your
head off on the street and be like he
talked crap about the governor you're
not allowed to do that like we're lucky
that we can protect us we're so lucky I
don't think we get it for very long to
be honest with you I think I think you
know we're we're slipping when it comes
to that polite society that moral
society that holds on to that you know
amazing life that we've grown up with I
think we're slipping away from that for
sure let's jump to the story from
Politico de Santa says he won't get
involved with Trump's potential
indictment in any way right now on
Twitter
it's heating up I'm seeing uh you know
Ben Shapiro he's quote tweeting Matt
Walsh internal Rift daily wire over
whether or not Rhonda santis could
should or would extradite Donald Trump
now it seems based on questions asked to
Defenders himself he's not going to get
involved in the indictment in any way
which sounds like he's saying outright I
will not extradite Donald Trump from
Mar-A-Lago to New York but
what happens to a country when a state
indicts a former president for the first
time in history who's also the current
front-runner
then the state that where he is says I
am not going to get involved he's not
getting extradited what do they do send
in the FBI to go extrad item why would
the FBI do it I don't know I read
somewhere that the Secret Service is
supposed to be the one in charge of this
like they're sent out to arrest exactly
so the Secret Service will act upon a
state warrant that doesn't seem to make
sense to me no none of it makes sense
yeah no I think if if you want to say
we're living in a simulation in the
computer type way that it feels like AI
is writing all of this yeah which GPI is
writing all of this trumpets we're
trying something new this is crazy this
is this is new you know I looked into it
um and a lot of times like the only time
that maybe a governor won't give someone
over might be like for death penalty
let's say and and they don't they one
state believes in it one another state
doesn't
um never for really something like this
obviously where it's a felony of guilty
or more likely you know this is more of
a misdemeanor but they're going after a
felony but it also gets just wrapped up
in the courts within the state the
problem is if DeSantis says he won't get
involved and he commits to that and this
is actually happening that he will he
will absolutely not uh not become
president of the United States whenever
he he wants that base to to support him
that Trump basis he needs that Trump
base it's not just about the Trump base
it would be an utmost sign of weakness
and a failure of leadership if he allows
Trump to be arrested also within his
speech that he's talking about uh you
know not getting involved he's saying
that it's political persecution
okay so if you're saying it and you're
admitting to it but you're also at the
same time saying you're not going to do
anything about it this is how you be a
leader like you're saying exactly
supporters happy like Jeb Bush you know
right Jeb Bush would like this rhetoric
from DeSantis yes that's why he has Jeb
Bush in his corner it's not even for
sure it's it's it's already bad enough
to say this wasn't strong enough in his
in his statement saying I'm not going to
get involved in any way is already bad
enough if he actually lets Trump be
extraded so here's what needs to happen
DeSantis if he wants to prove he's
presidential he says Donald Trump he he
needs to come out and say Donald Trump
will not be extradited from this state
under my watch for a political
persecution he is the front-runner for
the Republican party's 2024 presidential
run he is a former president and
everyone can see these charges are
political if you make any attempt to
come into my state I will use the full
force of the executive branch to stop
you that is presidential yeah but he's
not doing that he goes I'm not going to
get involved yeah and a lot of people
say like oh well Trump's been taking
Jabs at him I totally understand that I
totally get it but if you do have if you
are looking to run for president either
2024 or the session after you know if
you want to be a leader lead like what
you're saying I mean lead the way
everyone's uh people are saying oh well
he's just a governor for for Florida
what other what other Governors are
saying anything well nobody's a governor
that's in the position that DeSantis is
in what are they so scared of what is
everyone so scared of ask yourself this
question right now and I mean this with
the utmost sincerity what are you scared
of why didn't you
jump out of that plane when you went
skydiving the first time when you were
there with your friends and they opened
the door and then you changed your mind
the last minute and rode the plane back
down and said I just couldn't do it why
didn't you go down that double black
diamond with your friends when they went
skiing what are you scared of now in
those circumstances I get it what if my
parachute fails what if what if I go too
fast I crash I break my bones that I get
for Rhonda santis for a political
position what are you so scared of what
is anyone scared of when it comes to
standing up well what if some bad thing
happens bad things are already happening
they're talking about indicting a former
president for the first time on what we
know is complete BS charges well past
the statute of limitations to try and
stop him in any way they can from being
president because he's winning
what does Ron DeSantis fear by just
getting on camera looking straight into
it and saying Alvin Bragg go
yourself what is he so scared of I'm I'm
sorry I'm just frustrated because I am
absolutely sick in every capacity so
much of everyone being scared of
nebulous political consequences I
certainly don't give a and I'm
thinking to myself the last thing I'd
ever want to do is be in political
office but the more I see people even
like DeSantis refuse to say to the
camera in the Press y'all can go
yourselves then I'm just like we need
someone who's going to do it now I
really do get why Trump won in 2016. now
I really do get why I gained 12 million
voters and now I totally understand why
so many more people wear his hats fly
his flag because it's about time
somebody just said I don't care you
I'm doing it I think I think it's
because DeSantis is trying to Pander to
like the old school politics and he's
trying to be the the Trump anti-trump
figure but we're in a post-trump post
covid world where everything's upside
down everything's insane and chaotic but
he's like this very politically vague
statement is pre-covered pre-trump and
it's not going to go anywhere I don't
know who's trying to keep happy with
that kind of stuff and he's doing a
fantastic job within a state I mean he
really is but we're talking about the
fall of the nation that's at risk here
we're talking about political
persecution I mean hell how many months
ago did the Biden Administration
literally create a Ministry of freaking
truth things are ten times worse now you
need to buckle up you need to lead
because we're trying to save the country
from literally becoming an all-out
Banana Republic it's also we have data
we didn't have before we understand ESG
and the military-industrial complex and
the world you know the new world order
that the Swiss banks the world economic
performance trying to create we
understand how the CCP is influencing
social governance like we know so we see
what we want to avoid and I think that
it gives us an opportunity to create the
world in the American Image with like
decentralized autonomy and local
governance and property rights and gun
rights and speed and things like that if
we do nothing in bicker they're going to
create some autocracy where you get
kicked off the internet you get your
bank Stripped Away because you said
Daddy wrong like that's what they're
scared of yeah
you know and I think about it like the
reason Ron DeSantis gave the answer he
gave which was like okay a lot of people
were cheering for it some people rolled
their eyes I don't think it was strong
enough better than him saying well you
know if they want to arrest them they're
going to have to extradine them and I
guess that'll happen but it wasn't a
very strong statement you know what he's
worried about he's worried about his
polling numbers he's worried about when
he runs for the president eventually
announcing and then resigning or
whatever as he does he's worried that
it's going to look bad to a certain
voter base Suburban women are getting
angry and say oh he's so aggressive and
abusive and it's just like look man
he doesn't need to literally come out
and say go f yourself to Elven Bragg
it was not bad that he it was really
good actually he ragged on the Soros D.A
he says they're evil people destroying
things I give him total respect for that
because that is good that was the best
part of the speech I'm just saying like
he needs to come out and just outright
say there will not be an extradition of
Donald Trump while I am governor of
Florida mark my words you will and then
you know what I'd love to see you want
to know what really make him
presidential if when Secret Service
whoever does show up to Mar-A-Lago Ronda
Sanders himself stands in front of the
door and says make me you'll have to
move me physically the governor of this
state make that happen I dare you that'd
be gangster then people are going to be
like damn yeah that would be that would
be but he's not going to do it a real
place and I like DeSantis he's doing a
great job for sure yeah
you know I got it best even Trump
wouldn't do something like that yeah he
said he's not going to get involved
quotes uh or whatever so how does this
work extradition does it go through the
governor where the governor say yes or
no or does it happen completely separate
of the governor only the governor can
step in and stop it I'm I'm a to the
best of my understanding it's not
necessarily up to the governor obviously
they can come out and be the face of the
position of the state but I believe it
has to do with you know the courts
within the state not so much like the
government the governor just says yes
and and or or no and that's what it is I
don't believe it indicates he's going to
let him get extradited and he's not
going to step in to stop it because if
his if it's his job to do it and he says
I'm not getting involved that indicates
he's not going to do it but if his job
is all he can do really is stop it from
happening he says not get involved then
he's not going to stop it from happening
even if he was just like politically
posturing and and making it be known
even if he didn't have control even if
he said something like what Tim's saying
that would help you know what he's doing
right now is the exact opposite you know
who would do exactly what I just said
Kerry Lake yep yeah I was thinking
Carrie like 100 she told 100 100 and you
know it you you said it right away no
questions if carry a like if this was
happening in her State she would say you
will have to physically remove me and I
will I will stand in your way with my
own body to stop you from making this
arrest she would do it she's great man
yeah when I was with her in Phoenix I
remember thinking as I was talking to
her like this lady is actual
counterculture you know this this mom in
her nice dress like that's Counter
Culture because she was badass and she
met you could tell everything she says
she means that stuff you spent a lot of
time with her did you interview her uh
no it wasn't a lot of time but it was
well I guess it was a few days of being
court with her and then I interviewed
her uh individually like uh elsewhere
and yeah I thought she was incredible
incredible dude she's she's uh she's one
of the most interesting and most
effective potential like you know
Governors out there when it comes to how
she can handle the media there's yeah
probably no one better than her I agree
and with everything that happened with
the election with the misprinted ballots
and all of that stuff and the ongoing
lawsuits we'll see where it ends up but
after seeing everything that's happened
so far
and and this conversation we're having
right now
I actually think
if Donald Trump said she's going to be
the VP I'd say absolutely 100 yeah oh
for sure absolutely yeah and it was
before I was worried like well she look
you look she worked in media then she
ran for office for I think the first
time right I think so and then she
doesn't get the office so what's the
political experience of doing it not at
this point I'm kind of like I don't care
about I want the opposite of political
experience I want the media experience
and I want the tenacity and the the the
The Bravery so when I wrote that story
and I'm sitting in court I think it was
the first day for her trial and I'm
sitting next to this guy end up ragging
at the end of that story the corporate
NBC type guy who's just blatantly
misinterpreting the reality around him
she walks in sees him immediately and
looks at him and goes oh this guy writes
fantasy
yes it was amazing that's remarkable
yeah yeah she's incredible I wonder if
some people have speculated it might be
Carrie Lake for for VP would make sense
I I think that would make sense uh or
Vivek ramaswame at this point he is that
thrilling me because the same thing is
great he's being vocal and great people
people aren't smart yeah people or for
some reason questioning him I mean I
guess question everyone that's great but
uh he's he's been nailing every every
time he opens his mouth he's he's
incredibly intelligent he's incredibly
successful he's he's so motion oriented
I like that right one of the best assets
that GOP has right now he's not going to
be president with all due respect but
what he's doing with the conversation
yeah he's bringing up ESG and the
garbage which needs to happen and again
it's being brought to the front and
center he's really gonna Donald Trump
will I think right now based on all the
factors which is going to change in a
year and a half but if the election was
held today I think Donald Trump would
win but the conversation and the
priorities of that Administration would
be shifted by the victim you already see
it being shifted Vivek it was explicit
when he came on IRL when we were in um
at sea at a turning point that we what
we need to do is reposition our assets
our our investment assets onto a
different index that's not ESG sensitive
so put it in local just different
indexes create and use different indexes
and it's the same thing that uh that
Biden just vetoed is this bill to get
ESG out of our investments because
they're not profitable necessarily they
go for like social crap over profit yeah
and it's the same thing that DeSantis is
refusing to allow in his State and
there's a coalition of other states that
are refusing ESG West Virginia yep and
Virginia West Virginia was doing it I
think first it's really
yeah he's also he was on the ball he
might have been the first somewhat major
Republican that was speaking out against
Trump's potential yeah and calling out
other and calling out other Republicans
that weren't speaking about it he was he
was the first he literally if you if you
watch his videos he just grabs his cell
phone yeah he he he did it right away
yeah yeah he knew what he needed to do
he knew what the answer was and he
didn't waste a second to he didn't waste
a second for a big speech or anything
like that he he jumped straight to it
took it straight to Twitter that's the
kind of off the cuff stuff yeah strong
you know attitude that we liked about
Trump back then that I don't feel Trump
has now but I think being surrounded by
people like Carrie or Vivek would be
very very good for his cabinet I think
he's got Vivek has a vision so it's easy
to go off the cuff because he doesn't
have to worry about saying the wrong
thing because everything he already
knows what needs to be said to create
the vision
um I like that guy yeah I I I've I've
told this story before about well I'll
put this way there's that South Park
joke when the BP oil spill happened and
the guy's like we are sorry and then
he's laying in the naked in his
underwear like sorry it's too good but
that exemplifies everything about the
media The Establishment and the
politicians that I hate and I think many
Trump supporters despise every response
every action is canned predictable
garbage you know what they're going to
say before they say it because they have
to say the lowest common denominator
garbage talking point instead of just
telling you the truth and Donald Trump
went up on stage and said Rosie
O'Donnell was a fat pig and people were
like this guy's telling it like it is
Donald Trump went before the press and
said we're selling a bunch of weapons to
Saudi Arabia it's great so good for our
economy and that's important for Working
Class People to hear this is what
presidents do finally you have a guy
who's like screw off now here's here's
the thing Trump I think is the herald of
this personality not the world ruler
himself because everybody knows Donald
means World ruler and Trump means the
heralding sound I think he's he's he he
comes before something else I think he's
got to finish his Arc but there needs to
be somebody it might be Carrie Lake who
has the tenacity of trump but the
what's the what's I don't I don't know
the the
decorum I suppose it's you no but the
challenge is going to be to not go
psycho uh not me uh I'm saying that you
take somebody like Donald Trump who's
willing to tell the media to screw off
and F themselves who's willing to stay
on stage that Rose O'Donnell's a fat pig
I'm not saying it's a nice thing to do
I'm saying he was accused and he goes
only Rosie O'Donnell everybody laughs
take that brute honesty but add in that
more that the the decorum I suppose and
you have the leader yeah that might be
Carrie like we may be talking about
DeSantis prematurely because as much as
Carrie lake is not the governor
she's the only person I can think of who
would actually look into the camera and
tell brag to f off in the in the proper
political way you know what I mean yeah
instead of saying I'm not going to get
involved she'd say I will physically bar
him from entering my state you know what
I mean yeah the sentences in in a tricky
spot though because he can't run for
governor again so you know you could you
could use that momentum to run for
president that's why everyone you know
that's why everyone's talking about
DeSantis that's why you know there's
internal uh memos about like him or
people talking on the inside saying that
he's planning on running for president
he's now's his time right but I think
what Tim's getting to is also like
giving Trump that extra shot you have
you have you have a guy that has a
second term and that's it he is going to
go all out there's no worry or thought
about running again there's no oh if I
do this now I won't be electable for for
next election that's that's not a
concern he can go all out Maga Unleashed
Trump eyes glowing Super Saiyan I'm into
that I just hope he he makes up for the
out of the best stuff I really didn't
like at the end of the term not just the
partnings but I mean he's not this
lockdown so he kept fouchy in power he
did warp speed and I loved A lot of the
stuff he did prior to that but those
things almost outweigh the good for all
the Nerds he's Proto man and we need
Mega Man
true
I know Proto man was Dr light's first
creation oh yeah and then I think he
turned and went to work for Dr Wily or
something yeah but I do I would blame
some of that not all of it I think I
think Trump was very good at like
surrounding himself with people that
would consult around him that were just
awful at their jobs too yeah
um Trump also made a handful of
decisions on his own that were bad but I
think also there were some things that
they were they were making the move to
make it more electable for the next
election like there you can't go too
extreme yeah and it's like okay yeah
sure a lot of people just say do it go
for it right but you can also totally
botch your ability to get reelected and
so a lot of them keep that in mind when
they're trying to run for a second term
is like you can't get a hell of a first
term but like you can't go Unleashed
right uh your first term because it'll
just you'll shoot yourself in the foot
yeah and he with the lockdowns I mean he
he helped give him to us but he also did
then we had this debate about states
rights again about you know which state
can lock down which Camp which became
beautiful for DeSantis you know these
are these are good things to be arguing
but you know having faulty around to me
is a crime yeah
replaced immediately yeah and yeah for
all the years he's been there and all
the things he's done over the over the
decades in power he should not have been
there for this and he should have been
taken out immediately and I don't mean
that in a bad way I mean you know we
remove the I'm fired yeah yeah I
mean when it well I mean he was doing
what they want what I I think he was
doing what he wanted
in the medical industrial complex he was
working for that yes I like it I think
that the United States of people and
probably the world is at a point where
things the veil is becoming lifted like
the liberal economic order is turning
into the New World Order and now it's
been like head down don't say anything
about it you have all these Governors
like I just don't want to rock the boat
just keep pushing forward until we're
until it's done until I get to retire
whatever but it's like I think we got to
be honest about how the transition is
going to happen now for the people of
the United States I think a leader that
does that is invigorating and can build
the trust of the American people and
provide like a road map forward if
there's no road map man people are just
going to start smashing into each other
I don't know if we can have a road map
because we exist in different dimensions
like we were saying earlier with the two
screens or two ones it's the same meme
like so so we don't exist together
anymore so I didn't say this back let me
see if I can pull this meme up back
honestly I love the reference like
calling it The Matrix and people sitting
on the outside of the Matrix looking in
and then there's the people in The
Matrix that like will tell you you know
I hear all the time when I'm talking to
people on the street like new York Times
that is objective news that's what it is
okay you're on the outside it's not
liberal like they are not aware of any
biases that they have at all what they
believe is just the truth and you're the
exception this is the meme it says when
you are looking for the basic difference
between the left and the right look to
the young our 17 year old versus their
17 year old and this meme is shared by
the left and the right in the exact same
way to make the exact same point I just
want to make an argument real quick
about the simulation if you if you guys
remember they have the same birthday too
yeah
Luke encouraged him to get married this
is crazy Joe crazy well she's she's a
foreign leftist climate change Global
Elite and he is a working class Suburban
slash rural American kid but you're an
actor insane the other dimension they
flip it off and see her as the working
class right no no well I think they do I
think they see her as like this more
blue-collar like activist and they see
him as like this privileged elitist
honestly I actually I I think I think
one of them obviously stands for Liberty
and they are incredibly opposed to that
everything that that that that image
stands for they're incredibly opposed to
when it comes to like the liberal Elite
and control and and you know passing
more government regulation when it comes
to climate change and everything like
that that agenda is the most attractive
thing to them because that agenda to
them is safety it's that like government
controlled safe world that you live in
whereas the other one's a little bit
more risky but there's more Liberty I
can sense as they're keep advancing
carbon capture technology now like oil
companies are withdrawing the carbon
from the air and storing it underground
they're learning how to turn it into
graphene for building it's the the the
the the the momentum of the climate
change thing is fizzling you I can sense
it on the internet like it's just not
exciting to complain about the future of
carbon when people know you can easily
or at least actively pull it out like
it's becoming obvious that the next
problem is going to be taking too much
carbon out of the air that's really
interesting that you're saying that I'm
not even familiar with that uh but but
technology every single year it's like
just open New York better and better
they were they were concerned about
horse crap on the streets of New York
and the car got invented so do you guys
know about do you guys know about
15-minute cities
sort of I've heard this idea that in the
future everybody will live within 15
minutes of whatever they need you'll
never need to really go anywhere you'll
have whatever you want there's this
really funny video I just saw someone
send it to me and it's a guy explaining
15-minute cities and he says I want to
explain to you the concept of the
15-minute City and then he walks up to
the shed thing and opens it and there's
chickens standing there and he goes
these are its citizens inside their
15-minute City they have everything they
could ever need then they walk inside
and goes there is food and water readily
available now they can leave whenever
they want they don't want to because
it's scary and it's dangerous outside
and why inside here they own nothing but
they're happy and he said and then he
walks into the room and he's like this
is where they produce things that I can
take for free and then he picks the eggs
up and he puts them in his sweater and
he's like here's a couple here's a
couple and he's like see in the
15-minute City you will owe nothing
you'll be happy you'll be provided for
and then we can take everything from you
it really is a great video explaining
what their plan is how the how these
city planners how these how the Davos
group types want to run the show
treating us like chickens making us do
the work that they can take and keeping
you locked in a chicken coop I want you
living and dying on an assembly line you
know that's it do you think as you guys
were saying that I was like well they
don't want him doing that they want like
a thinking class of people to join them
basically like do you guys think about
the plebs and the elites like do you
think there's a class differential the
Romans would say that's the plebs was it
like a nutrition issue like all these
people they're from people that didn't
have nutrition for Generations they've
been bred to be stupid workers and then
the Elite Class have all the good food
they can think they can write the law
yeah it's the the what is the morlocks
and the which ones that I don't know was
it warlocks yeah I know what you're
talking about yeah time machine or
something
uh
I'm looking at morlocks uh fictional
species
in the antagonists or the morlocks in
the he goes to the Future where humans
have evolved into two different species
one's really dumb and one's really smart
this is from The Time Machine yeah oh
Loi that's what it is
take a look at this article in the daily
mail if there's a civil war I'm fighting
Trump loyalists face off with staunch
liberals outside former presidents NYC
tower on the eve of his room at arrest I
saw this article and I thought it was
really funny considering the context
because like
I appreciate the protesters right but I
was thinking about it and like I see
this picture of this dude I don't know
who he is uh Diane cine 54 founder of
trumpswag.com eating that cheeseburger
in the french fries and I'm like
look he doesn't look like he's out of
shape or anything I'm just like think
about what this Civil War is going to
look like it's not gonna so like the
Confederates had just I don't know if
you guys have ever seen a true
Confederate uniform very basic Union
uniforms were like blue or whatever it
was all very basic mass-produced stuff
but like a modern Civil War is going to
be weird as hell there's gonna be people
wearing like Uniqlo turtlenecks and
antifa it'll be like Walmart versus
forever 21. those are the outfits well I
mean worse than that it's gonna be like
hunger City like Hunger Games Capital
City people with like you know half
their head is shaved and the hair is
spiked to the side and they've got weird
body modifications and they're going to
be waving gigantic multi-colored flags
of all different kinds you can't discern
who is on what side because all the
flags are different but all you know is
that their flag doesn't have Trump on it
they're probably not on your side then
you're gonna have people waving Trump
flags of all different types and it's
like it's gonna get crazy yeah it'll be
that they them Army against uh probably
probably a pretty that'd be they'd be
pretty heavily armed I would imagine the
right wing would be you know yeah a lot
of people bring up like the military
getting involved and whatnot I would
imagine if it were to actually go down
it's not like military versus you it's
military splits as well same as the
nation military leaders that are more
whiteling and you know believe in
whatever they would believe in and
people die with that science man I think
people really need to start reading
about the Civil War because I am by no
means an expert in any way but even just
visiting Gettysburg I'm like oh I guess
so much I did not know like for instance
I learned when I went to Gettysburg that
one of the reasons the Confederates lost
was because they were muzzle loaded
rifles but they unioned It upgraded to
breach loading rifles that means the
union would breach loading is you you
crack the gun kind of breaks in half on
a hinge like like a shotgun you know you
ever see like Elmer fud load a shotgun
breach load you break it open you put
the shell in you close it you can fire
the Confederates were trying to muzzle
load and the Union soldiers were just
firing
boom real quickly that was a
technological advantage a lot of people
don't know that they don't know what
happened or why most people don't know
the Confederates could have won the war
in the first fight I think the First
Battle of Bull Run they could have just
walked into DC and and won instantly and
they decided not to there's so much so
much but the important thing is the
reason I bring it up how I think it was
like was it Lee who was talking they're
all they're all West Point guys and then
they were like but I can't fight against
my own State I have no choice but to
leave and go back home right people
don't get that that you're gonna have
somebody who's gonna be like I grew up
here you are not gonna send me to occupy
my own Street Corner somebody who was
born and raised in West Virginia who's
like now living in DC because it's only
about an hour two hour drive depending
on where you're at I mean if you're in
Central West Virginia it could be four
or five hours but then they're like okay
now we're gonna have you go with this
gun to to you know your state and
they're gonna be like I don't know if I
can do that right yeah that will happen
Shelby Foote is a historian someone I
was looking at a lot reading when I was
writing this book and he said he's from
the south he said something about the
union thought they were fighting to keep
the union together and the South was
fighting the second American Revolution
but there are a lot of people who lived
down there who didn't give a crap about
the war at all but if you came into
their territory they're going to fight
you which to the union looks like you're
a Confederate but they're just defending
their property executive as an invading
Force exactly yeah in the South they
were like there would be sons who saw
the north as an invading force and their
fathers fought the British and the
revolution who saw the British as
innovating Force yeah so it's like two
generations in a row basically of
fighting invading forces and that's
crazy super crazy wow it's wild I mean I
haven't even checked out any of that
stuff like I haven't gone to any of
those Battlegrounds
Gettysburg is cool cool place I mean the
whole city is basically a civil
warper yeah
we we ride our bikes past Antietam like
whenever we whenever we're going up uh
we go up to uh what's that little town
uh do you know which one it is
Hagerstown no no there's a little little
bitty one Sharpsburg Sharpsburg yeah
yeah the best ice cream in America I
know for those that don't know there's
like this really Fame it's like a dollar
for this bowl of ice crazy yeah but I
mean right there and it's it's beautiful
and they have they they they've put up
all of these Civil War informational
things everywhere you go we're really
close to John Brown's uh raid
headquarters in Harpers Ferry John
Brown's house is the only place I ever
felt a black lives matter flag should be
I was like okay that that makes sense
there the one in Ohio for John Brown no
in Harpers Ferry I agree because I think
they would but like you would like it
John Brown I think was a crazy was a
crazy person well I think he had
something right about slavery being bad
yeah he would have about it the wrong
way but that's the problem I had with
antifa too right like antifa is like hey
there's a bad thing happening in
government like yeah I really agree
about that so I did you fire bomb a
black person's business right and you
know it's like well I don't like dude
John Brown raids an Armory and none of
the slaves wanted to fight with him they
were like dude what are you doing with
all his sons yeah yeah and it's just not
to mention he just went and murdered
people and then there's played in Kansas
and all that stuff A lot of people are
like dude we agree with you but
this is not the way we go we want to go
about doing it I don't know I don't
think he was right but there's a
question of whether or not the the
people who are refusing to fight were
right I believe he thought slavery was
just going against God and he was had a
calling by God I believe he was trying
to do it right but he wasn't right about
going violating people in the face the
violence part is where I stopped too is
I don't obviously don't want violence
yeah I think of that I think the first
person hanged by the federal government
was that true I I think no he was one of
the Virginia I'm pretty sure I think it
was one of the first people I forget
what it was I have to look that up one
of the first people of something but
yeah I've been following all those
things we did a video the other day
asking people if um the Civil War was
enough payment for like slavery
reparations and stuff like if that was
enough payment in terms of what like in
terms of like there's talk about just a
bunch of cash but yeah yeah the
Bloodshed and stuff seeing like hey was
that a sufficient payment for slavery or
no I love when white people are saying
that uh this they did nothing white
people did nothing for slavery I'm like
well white people also did fight the
Civil War and won it you should know and
stopped it right not only did hundreds
of thousands of lines like two million
horrible yeah
uh in this book that are based on like
diary entries from different soldiers
from all over the place and some from
both sides that you could smell the
blood in their diet like in terms of how
they write it between six between 600
and 1 million dead yeah and so on the
union side you had 290 000 dead Union
Soldiers
the Confederate side was 365 000 dead
soldiers the total casualties injured
prison of Wars Etc 864
000 on the union side and 828 000 on the
Confederate side so it's like 290
000 people died 864 000 people suffered
some kind of injury is that not enough
for the country to be ripped apart
for people to be shooting and killing
each other for the the march to the sea
the ransacking and destruction of the
burning of Richmond none of that when
they come out and they're like this
country was both on slavery it's like
and it's also burned down partly because
of it so I mean I kind of feel like you
know the payment's done you know when
slavery was abolished there was the
population was like 25 million people so
I you know they're they're it's
obviously it's evil what was happening
with slavery but to to suggest that uh
the country was built on slavery it's
like really the slaves built New York or
like what are you talking about I mean
to be fair like in a certain respect yes
in a lot of these places slaves did
construction slaves worked at the stores
and a lot of people don't understand
this either most most I would imagine if
you ask one you should maybe do this
most Americans view of a slave is
probably coming from these movies where
it's like a a black man in the field
being whipped what they don't also
realize is that a lot of slaves were
like cobblers and they were people there
were people in cities working at stores
and do doing regular trade work but they
just weren't getting they weren't free
to leave they couldn't do whatever they
wanted they couldn't own property they
couldn't read or write or or some of
them could but they typically couldn't
people understand that slaves did all
manners of work and like none of it was
good you keep taking away someone's
agency to strip them from from the work
they produce is like the antithesis of
what this country is supposed to be but
in that respect yeah in places like New
York slaves did provide a large
component and then the country ripped in
half
shot at each other like crazy cities
were burnt to the ground
nearly 2 million people suffered some
kind of casualty with nearly a million
dead and I'm kind of like what is that
125th the entire population suffered uh
died what was let me let me let no that
that's right that's right yeah I think
25 million would probably be a high uh
estimate during the the Civil War is
that adult age or uh total I think
that's total I believe that's off the
top of my head 25 million uh in 31
million people
there were third in 1860 the US
population was 31 million I wonder how
many adults so one thirtieth of the
country died
because of yeah mostly because of
slavery I mean you ask people who are
from the south and who have family in
history they'll tell you it wasn't
because of slavery and
people need to understand the Nuance
there it's like you were saying yeah for
somebody who just lived in you know I
don't know Arkansas or something you've
got Union Soldiers marching through
shooting burning and you're like I don't
know or care you know you're fighting
right the other thing is I people will
will look at the Civil War and be like
the Union's all good Confederates all
bad I mean if you know anything about
history it's just that's such a false
word looking at it pretty sure the most
evil dude in the whole thing was Sherman
Sherman hated black people uh I wrote
about it fairly extensively and then
also was okay with one of his one of his
guys who was I believe a general uh
someone beneath him though so you're not
a general but he was a union guy who
happened to be named Jefferson Davis
oddly enough so the simulation's been
happening since the Civil War but this
this Union soldier named Jefferson Davis
was in charge of they didn't they didn't
like freed slaves following them so they
killed them they pulled out the bridge
from beneath them as they were trying to
cross a river in Georgia during the
march of the sea killed them I believe
it was hundreds I put it in the book
it's a crazy thing real quick for people
who don't know the march to the sea I
believe was the first instance of
scorched Earth scorched Earth here yeah
yeah dude scorched Earth refers to in
war destroying arable land burning down
houses killing civilians Etc so that
nothing can be rebuilt and you decimate
their their chances they would
reconstruct they would make Sherman
neckties they'd burn the railroad tracks
and and then pull them and stretch them
around trees so the trains couldn't get
to the Confederate camps uh burned
everything down and there's a lot of
people who would claim that Sherman came
to their house and burnt it down but
they're also people who were like uh
advantageous and become Marauders and
had nothing to do with Sherman but then
went and destroyed things to pilfer
because that's still his fault exactly
yeah because he created the atmosphere
where where it's actual hell on Earth he
said he wanted to make the South uh I
believe squeal scorched
I put this in the book I look at Sherman
as our first atom bomb you know and he
he went down to the South and just
decimated and those people are reeling
from that to the today like in the town
in the book you know even though Sherman
didn't make it to this exact Town these
people have family dating back to the
revolution in Georgia pre-georgia pre
United States and they're still feeling
like effects from just how decimated
Georgia was from the sea so for the
people who are in the south
because there was a percentage of these
states who were in favor of staying with
the union and who opposed slavery in
fact Virginia initially voted to stay
with the union and it wasn't until the
federal troops got sent down to Fort
Sumter that they just or I think it was
slightly after this they were like whoa
this is getting crazy we're going to
break off and then four more states
joined so for what people don't realize
is that these states weren't in unison
being like hurray a secession there was
a vote and there was a split and there
was debate yeah so let's say you're a
family that just happened to live in
Georgia let's put it this way let's put
it in a modern context let's say you are
living in Shepherdstown West Virginia
it's like fairly woke huh oh yeah but
you're in West Virginia which is 86
percent Mago imagine if there was a
Civil War and West Virginia being modern
country gets gets invaded by Union
soldiers and then the the union let's
say Federal National Guard come in take
over your house occupy it you have no
idea why even though you're like I don't
agree with these people I don't like
what's going on they just there's
gunfights and they burn down your
property and everything you're family
owned is now gone do you deserve
reparations
after the war is done immediately after
should they come and say we're sorry
that our invasion of the state had a
negative impact on you we are going to
help rebuild your home actually at the
uh that's there's actually I believe
like a statute for that um because it's
like during some current uh it has to
follow around like a current time so you
would deserve reparations
immediately after if the federal
government did something like that too
and I will say real quick about the
massacre about uh with what I was saying
with Sherman and March to see Lincoln
did go down and then he took some land
from people and gave it to the families
of the free slaves that who did survive
well so yeah here's my point let's say
you were a family in Georgia and you're
like we don't we don't like slavery we
don't be involved in slavery we don't
want to secede from the union we can't
control it we're not in politics we're
just some farmers who mind our own
business then Sherman comes walks up to
your house and throws a torch in it
destroys everything you your kids
struggle to survive maybe some siblings
die now it's a hundred or so years later
and you're living in a trailer where
your family used to be you know farmers
of of modest living and moderate living
you are now impoverished do you deserve
reparations for the destruction the
Union forces brought to your land if
it's 100 years later I have a hard time
saying yes to that I'm not saying yes or
no I'm saying when they go to
Californians and say we're gonna give
you operations despite the fact that
California was admitted as a free state
and has always been against it it's like
it's just absolutely ridiculous yeah
it's a virtue well what they're talking
about in California is San Francisco
they're talking about five million
dollars per uh descendant of slave or
whatever you have to check a couple
boxes there's like eight options and if
you check like a few of them or whatever
you can get five million dollars and
it's like an unbelievable amount of
money but also California as a whole
July they have 223 000 that they're
trying to give to
um each Senator slave in the state you
don't need to be black you need to
identify as black it did say that yeah
it's true and so we went over this and
there's there's certain criteria where
someone like Rachel dolezal will be
eligible no joke let's uh but let's
let's let's move on from world baby I
think they should do it look I got to
mention too the the Greta Kyle
Rittenhouse birthday thing is really
crazy it's crazy but let's move on to
the next apocalyptic story and that's
the uh the banking collapse because we
have this from The Washington Post why
17 billion dollars in Credit Suisse
bonds became worthless I don't care
about Credit Suisse it's a big like it's
imploding UBS what is that uh United
banking system or something like that
don't want to check I think Union or
something let's just double check
because I was I forget
what is it
it's not telling me it's not telling you
oh you look at that group yeah it's got
to be just do UBS Wiki bro anyway the
best bank of Switzerland Union Bank of
Switzerland you see there you go They're
gonna buy us formerly the Union Bank of
Switzerland then they changed it to UBS
I see but what is okay it used to stand
for something now it just stands for you
because it's an investment bank so so
UPS is going to buy Credit Suisse but
their bonds are worthless what people
are basically saying is that the whole
system is collapsing and we have this
tweet from Balaji which is very shocking
to the point where it's got a lot of
people angry
he says
I will uh so so James Medlock says I
will bet anyone one million dollars the
U.S does not enter hyperinflation
Balaji says I will take that bet now
this guy is the former CTO of coinbase
which is a crypto exchange he says you
buy one Bitcoin I will send one million
dollars in USD
This is 40 to 1 odds as one Bitcoin is
worth 26 000 it's currently like 28. the
term is 90 days all we need is a
mutually agreed custodian who will still
be there to settle this in the event of
digital dollar devaluation he is saying
outright
he thinks that one Bitcoin will be worth
one million dollars in three months
and the argument is
he shows these graphs about
Federal Reserve weekly remittances to
treasury look at this going back to
2011. even when things were bad they
weren't this bad
whoa look at uh unrealized gains and
losses even when they were bad it was
never this bad
he's got another one showing all the
same things and we already saw that
other uh with this other tweet that we
talked about last week that said the
bond market is predict believes the
system has already collapsed
if that's the case what he's arguing is
people think we live in an analog world
it's exactly how he says it
and that means
analog takes a long time
but we're not in that world anymore it's
digital information transmission is
instant which means it's either one or
it's zero everybody knows it happened or
nobody knows it happened back in the day
if there was a market collapse the only
people who knew were the people at the
market they're in the stock exchange
going what's happening then they they
send Pony Riders out with letters to
inform the investors who then Panic
there's I can't remember what show I was
watching or a movie or something where a
guy goes to withdraw money in California
but the bank has shut down and so he has
to race the bank Messengers to a
Northern Bank to beat the message the
idea is the company's freezing
withdrawals because they're going out of
business or something like that's
happening bank's collapsing so the bank
he goes he says sorry sir you can't have
your money because we're shutting down
he then has to get to a northern branch
which is like three hours ride before
the messenger gets there because if he
gets there first he'll withdraws money
then the messenger comes and shuts it
down that's how it used to it's crazy
today before you even know they've
already made a phone call
so what's going to happen when people
finally realize the banks are bust it's
going to be near instantaneous that the
dollar breaks that's his bet a lot of
people are calling him crazy because for
Bitcoin to reach one million dollars in
three months I told him I'll take his
bet my worst here's what I'll do I said
I'll buy two Bitcoin 56 000 it's 50 what
is it it's at 27 29 28 right now 28. so
56 000 and my worst case scenario is
when when I lose one of those Bitcoin
I'll get a million dollars for my 56
000. I'm not gonna cry about it right so
that's why I'm like I can't believe
those odds is is he saying I he's saying
I will send he will send one million he
made a bet with this guy so I hit him up
we're gonna we're gonna try and do some
kind of we might I might do a show with
him for the culture War we'll figure it
out but he is saying that he is going to
put up one million dollars cash
for one Bitcoin
that's that that's the wager because
he's betting the buying power of the
dollar becomes trash and the Bitcoin
becomes worth a million I think he's
attempting to instill confidence when
you talk about economics confidence is
the backbone of the economic system
people don't believe in the currency
they won't use it and it loses value so
he's attempting to create value for
Bitcoin but I think it sounds freaking
insane he's asking for a 10 40 times
increase in the value of Bitcoin in the
next 90 days 40 times increase so a lot
of people are saying he's trying to
create a self-fulfilling prophecy by
making this bet he's gotten a ton of
attention what's the traffic on the
Tweet I'm curious 11.5 million views
there's traffic on it yeah and there's a
bunch of news stories have been written
about it because
he he said he he told me he's doing it
he's going to put up the million dollars
in cash the dude's probably worth
several hundred million or whatever he's
an early Bitcoin investor so he's
probably very loaded and can easily
afford to do the million dollars but
this guy needs only to bet 26 thousand
dollars
for a chance to win one million is that
a bet worth taking it does he lose the
Bitcoin to the guy if it doesn't yes
appreciate it that's that's the point
of money you don't have no no no no no
no no he doesn't lose it oh well then
the worst case scenario is you still
have your Bitcoin in 90 days no no no no
no no no no listen listen
Balaji Wagers one million in cash and
this guy James Medlock wages one Bitcoin
and then the winner takes both yes I see
right yeah don't don't bet money you
don't have you don't you don't take both
you just don't lose what you have right
you know what I mean so if the guy buys
a Bitcoin and it stays at thirty
thousand dollars in 90 days he gets a
million bucks
so so what's what's what's what's what's
the downside so is he going to take this
is he's doing this deal with more than
one person or is this just like a person
he said you know here's what here's the
thing he said he was going to do it with
two two people
uh he said I will do it with Medlock and
one other person sufficient to prove the
point so I reached out to him and said
bro I'll do it and I don't even disagree
with you about Bitcoin and the banks I
just disagree on the 90 days thing did
he respond to you he said he's only
going to do with this one guy but he'll
come on and we'll talk about it which I
think would be really great however I
don't think he's in the U.S so we've got
ah we'll try and figure something out I
was like maybe we can do something for
the culture War podcast where you know
or I'll just do a short segment for
timcast news because I think talking to
him about this is is important so he's
making this bet with one person am I
just yeah I'm just making this clear one
person okay one person and that person's
already been selected it's the guy who
said we're not going to enter
hyperinflation okay okay I don't care
about the Bitcoin thing look if you
don't care about Bitcoin ignore this
it's fine but what you should care about
is is the data he provides on the
banking system collapse
so of course his whole perspective is
Bitcoin is better
but what he's showing in terms of his of
his sources is the unrealized losses and
massive collapse of treasuries bonds and
the banking system yeah this is the
collapse you wonder if things are going
to collapse we are in the collapse right
now that is why banks are buying other
banks that is a sign of the collapse
that's the bailouts this is what people
don't realize either UBS buying Credit
Suisse is the bailout is what's going to
happen here's my prediction
you got First Republic Bank is is
crumbling the shares dropped again like
35 bounce to minus eight it was like
minus 35 then minus 18. there's a
despite the fact they're gonna do a 30
billion dollar infusion despite the fact
that the Fed was going to put in what I
think like 2 trillion or something
what's gonna happen is a bank will buy
the failing bank and they'll say see it
got bought out then the FED will issue
their easing or loans to the bank who
made the purchase as a way of doing a
workaround bailout instead of doing a
direct government bailout or a direct
fed bailout a private bank will make the
purchase and they'll say no there's no
banks collapsing they were just
mismanaged and this powerful Private
Bank bought them up there's nothing here
making it stronger and then that private
bank behind the scene says okay fed Pony
up and if that would be like printing
the money as we speak and they give them
a bigger loan because their new
valuation with the new acquisition of
the new bank makes their company worth
more money this is the UBS is actually a
result of a merger that's why they went
from uh Union Bank of Switzerland in
1998 they bought Swiss Bank Corporation
became UBS I think this global bank
conglomeration things massively
dangerous uh because it gives a small
group of people the ability to turn off
your money so let's let's let's yes yeah
let's play a game real quick
21 Bitcoin right now is at twenty eight
thousand you said yeah and it is
unfathomable to us that it could reach
one million dollars in 90 days I mean
maybe a hundred thousand because it was
at sixty something it's Peak last time
but what if I were to say this
what if I were to say not that Bitcoin
is going to go from twenty six thousand
to one million dollars in ninety days
what if I was to say the second and
third largest banking collapse in U.S
history would happen within two days of
each other would you believe that you'd
say what in two days
the the second and third biggest banking
collapse imagine if he came out before
Silicon Valley Bank collapsed when
silvergate first broke and he said I
will bet you
one million dollars in cash
you put up 26 000 I put up one million
if I'm right I get 26 if you're right
you get a million in two days the second
and third largest banking collapses in
history will happen who would not take
that bet they'd be like shh you think
hit two two black swanimate two
historical moments are gonna happen in
two days
I'll do that bet I'm gonna win a million
bucks and then you'd lose 20 grand you
lose 25 Grand I think it's if I think
it's more likely that Wells Fargo
collapses on Friday than it is that
Bitcoin is a million dollars and 90 days
I think it's more likely we're going to
see the biggest bank in the world
collapse than Bitcoin go to because what
they're gonna they're gonna artificially
control the value of Bitcoin they're
gonna Jack it up then there's going to
be a bunch of people will buy then all
the top dollars will sell off then it'll
drop again and the whole time they'll be
getting ready to switch out your US
dollars for U.S Central Bank coins so
you're not gonna have to worry about
dollars and then they're going to make
Bitcoin look like a bad guy and they
make the usdc look awesome the digital
currency is like maybe even if they
didn't hit a million dollars it would be
there for like a week and then it would
fall to 300 yeah
jacket up to 60 again and then all these
people will buy and they're like I
missed the boat it'll be 80 and then the
huge sell-off I mean I that's what
they've been doing is I don't know the
scary thing is if Bitcoin starts rising
to a million rapidly then a bunch of
people buy in and then it drops to 40.
and then everyone's dead broke and they
say C is the problem of crypto you need
a stable cryptocurrency that we can
moderate create a depression bring in a
new banking system federal reserves
digital crypto Asset Management fund and
then they say for all those who saw
tremendous losses due to bitcoin we will
be issuing us digital coin fed coin
so that you can you know have some money
back as a major bailout to the Working
Class People every liberal will be like
the government should bail these people
out Bitcoin was a scam the whole time
and we've all been saying it and this is
what the what Bales are for are you
opposed to the people being bailed out
that could be the whole plan yeah I've
been kind of like uh accepting this
digital currency this USBC I find myself
kind of feeling defeated and like oh
what they're going to do this is going
to happen but like Vivek ramaswamy's re
super against it like no we are not
having a digital we're not going into
the ESG you mentioned just a few moments
ago like turning off people's ability to
grab their money or use their money when
it came to like uh Banks merging that
would be way worse dude if two guys in
West Virginia were trying to buy
hamburgers and then some Banker in
Switzerland was like no sorry dude
that's why we fought a revolution you
don't get to control my money that's my
job that's my Congress that's why we
have a congress yeah I I don't see a way
that you know if if they if the
government gets involved in that I don't
I don't see a way that like that doesn't
go south incredibly quickly just like in
California when they were turning off
thermostats or was it California both uh
oh that might have been it might have
been Colorado but they were turning off
the thermostats right it doesn't
Colorado like yeah like that I reject I
don't like uh electric cars for that
reason because they're talking about
turning off cars or making them drive
back to the dealership or whatever if
they're being repoed you know there's
not having your autonomy is disturbing
yeah that that world with digital
currency well although I like it if the
government is in control of it I reject
that it would like imply you have to
have a second secondary currency you
would have to you cannot rely on digital
which is what crypto should be now
before it's regulated by the government
that should be your it is but cash is
good because it's you can't track it or
it supposedly is untrackable and it's
just between you and the receiving party
people now yeah like if a dude sells his
cow to somebody for some cheese why is
anyone in the world involved in that is
so weird I understand maybe low local
taxes maybe because you were cleaning up
the roads you want to make sure that
it's not raining poop on the cow so like
we've got fire department making sure
your barn doesn't burn down just let me
buy a cow in peace without any
government you know I just want to be
I'm I'm quickly becoming Off the Grid as
fast as possible and as much as possible
we're not going that direction anytime
soon we're going further and further
into more taxes more
businesses
every transaction possible and do you
know about the line the city in Saudi
Arabia I saw it I don't know much about
it but I but I did see it incredibly
creepy it sounds dystopian fake but
apparently they're actually going to
build it yeah I think they got uh it's a
13-minute city it's one of these things
where they put all the humans in one
little box that's attractive to a lot of
people today that's a lot of people want
to live that way so gross a border wall
I think it was uh God someone was
calling it a border wall but you can
live in these are the people that get to
fight when the Border gets attacked
because they're the one that live in the
border wall just cannon fodder up front
yeah human Shields they're human shield
and you're 15. no haven't there been
studies where it's like they they
compare it to cities with like rats and
everybody's really close and there's a
lot more illnesses and all that stuff
yeah won't they see outbreaks like like
that in an areas such as that or with
that yes
you're crucial I mean all that stuff I
feel like they tried the same thing
while the line but with rats and it's
worked out awfully you have to be
massively vaccinated in your 15-minute
city as well
every day probably you see that video
that's going around to fouchy walking
around asking people yes and they're
yelling at them classic it's remarkable
it's from 2021 wow it just came out
what's can we play a bit of that yeah
we'll get it up on the members only and
then some voice chats from the Discord
server he goes to some dude's house and
it's like trying to serve him the
vaccine and the guy's like hey that like
the flu and they're like well it's
different than the flu isn't it weird
when you try to pay someone to take it
yeah they're like actually that is kind
of weird Muriel Bowser agrees with the
guy yes great yeah Ian that that
response from that guy I knew I knew
that was going to be the response as
soon as I saw the guy I was like okay
I've talked to I talked to like enough
like black Americans on the street to
where like they are so conservative and
upfront and will give you the facts or
get like just say it the way it is every
single time I knew exactly what we were
going to get and it's a shock that
they're not like overwhelmingly
conservative because they they tell you
how it is and he responded exactly how
like any person on the street if I were
to go talk to somebody about that any
any black male that I would talk to on
the street they'd say the same thing
it's super straightforward about it
super based response and you're like
shocked that they still the you know the
black community in the United States
overwhelmingly votes Democrats it
doesn't make it well I guess it kind of
makes sense because they tend to you
know jump on the on the on the race
topics and topics and everything like
that but uh it was it was an awesome
video far and wide their values are lean
conservative well that's what I'm saying
they're incredibly democracy too like I
was looking at Carter he was fairly
concerned people looked at him and
they're like they don't know if he's
conservative or liberal back in the day
because he had conservative values it's
a conservative Community for sure 100
and I knew I knew he was gonna respond
like that too when I saw the video and
it was awesome it's also okay to
distrust the government fully and uh you
know that guy knew immediately something
was fishy if they're coming around I
mean that was probably around the same
time that the mayor of New York City was
saying I'll give you a hamburger I think
they're I think they're paying for it
they were giving you roller coaster
rides hamburgers fries paying you for it
cruise ships like if you guys are paying
me to take this this is all this is as
many red flags as I need
while you were talking you said that
something about a black male and then I
thought about the word blackmail which
is like where you force someone to do a
crime for you I'm like what what is this
black and white crap like black is the
evil dark color and so many things night
and day and then they tell like you're
the black person you're the white a
being of light like you're The Godly
white person and you are the dark black
like come on you're running too much
into it right right night time series
into it uh white light and dark white
and black had to do with daylight being
warm and safe and it made plants grow
and darkness was scary and they were
predators and you were cold and
obviously at night dark Skin Blends in
and Darkness and Light Skin reflects in
the Moonlight but that's not it
nobody's black and white what's that
it's not a skin color thing no yeah
night and dark that's what night comes
from like when they would fight at night
and they couldn't see their opponents is
a big part of it why the racism never
never heard that no bro you yeah like I
appreciate something real about you how
long ago are you talking about oh
before electricity ancient were they
fighting with knives and stuff and what
in the woods dark woods and stuff but in
the darkness you can't see anybody it's
not like white people are glowing you
might be catch in the moon like kind of
like glimpses of what's happening is you
are making an interesting point however
I think that point would would not be
brought up if you read about it before
saying it
the issue the issue is simple psychology
it's not even about skin color there are
people who uh uh would wear certain
clothes yeah yeah paint their faces
black at night like Navy Seals no no no
no I'm saying in Europe thousand years
ago they would see somebody wearing a
certain kind of clothes and go it's an
enemy it didn't matter what the race was
it was just an outsider Outsiders were
dangerous so racism is born of the same
thing as if you're different from me
it's the easiest thing someone could
notice right away to see that you are
not from my city you are not part of my
my group and that was a threat if I
don't know you how am I supposed to know
if it's safe to be around you and so you
get racism we are learning a lot about
why we that's stupid because people are
people so we have communications now
like we have we have cell technology
that that's really proximity Is what is
what ends bigotry as it were yeah anyway
I digress I just want to go back to that
money stuff real quick because you know
someone pointed out who cares about
Bitcoin in a million what about Doge
yeah what about Doge you know I would
love it if it always got up to 100 bucks
I had those because I just checked and
I'm like oh I have Tosh I don't know
where it is though I did I know nothing
about crypto but I did get those just
you know somebody somebody mentioned and
I looked and I'm like I have quite a bit
of Doge
makes sense and then it went to like 70
cents or something that's probably when
I sold when Elon was on uh SNL and it
yeah what did it yeah
did one of you guys just say this and I
just wasn't listening it it did a peak
right no it goes is at about seven cents
right had a had a Renaissance a few
years ago I made more off Doge than I
did as a professor uh at a college oh
really that's awesome yeah it was great
yeah I think but it dropped the crazy
thing is
it was at like
a a tenth of a cent oh yeah 2020 yeah
right wow could you imagine two
hundredths of a cent they're a Dogecoin
millionaires if it was at
yeah two two tenths of us four tenths of
a cent in 2020 it was at one tenth of a
cent so imagine if you bought
ten thousand dude in 2017 when it was
two hundredths of a cent I was like this
trash get this trash coin crap off my
index I'm tired of looking at this junk
I tired of these coins that go under and
they're what year was that no 2017.
Dogecoin is probably gonna be
like something it was pure junk trash
and then either on was like joked about
it now yeah but but the reason why is I
think Elon pointed this out Dogecoin is
an inflationary coin that's meant to
slowly increase the supply of Doge
available intentionally as because
demand will go up whereas Bitcoin is
deflationary at a certain point there
will be no more Bitcoin and it will
slowly cease to exist
Dogecoin can never fall out of
circulation based on its how it
functions so some people have speculated
that doge is cash and and Bitcoin is
gold
gold isn't I mean I'm sure at some point
we'll figure out how to I'm sure we can
manufacture gold somehow with some kind
of like yeah yeah we can use platinum
with hydrogen I think that's how it's
happening in the sun there you go and
eventually we'll get there the problem
Doge was when it was uh up to whatever
it was 60 or 70 cents yeah those apps
those trading apps were shutting down so
people couldn't sell and they were like
you can't they were saying sending out
messages like you can't do this or
whatever wait is my money do you buy
like ethereum to get doge is that what
it is
separate yeah is it okay separate I
don't know different cryptos I think
ethereum was like that as more of like
uh established I am not giving anybody
advice I don't know what you should do
I'm just saying I have Dosh because I
bought it a long time ago yeah I
actually I bought it when it was only a
few cents yeah I mean I think I bought
it what was the high was it was it 2020
or 2021 that it was reaching its peak 21
yeah it was like March 21. it was when
the whole Wall Street thing was
happening okay
a lot of them oh heck yeah
quite a ton for his kids and it went
from 63 cents to 30 cents which is
within like five within a month so
within two days it dropped 20 cents I
mean it dropped 15 cents so it peaked
and then everybody sold yeah it's all
confidence some people are pointing out
with this Balaji thing that when he says
you buy one Bitcoin and I'll send a
million dollars if people are like okay
let's say the guy holds 100 Bitcoin he
only needs Bitcoin to go up like a
couple percentage points to cover the
cost of the bet if Bitcoin goes up ten
percent he's gonna make way more money
than it cost by doing the stunt so it's
like yeah you know who knows who knows I
think doge is on the binance smart chain
it's different than the ethereum smart
chain so you use different tokens to buy
it um but there are places like coinbase
that'll do that for you where you can
buy it with cash see the thing I don't
like about the way doge is built is the
infinite Supply Tim was talking about
earlier because it just allows for
infinite inflation and devaluation of
the currency whereas you can always take
a Dogecoin and then sell one tenth of it
or 100th of it or one thousandth of it
so you don't need an infinite Supply you
can always break it apart infinitely or
at least so many times that you have a
huge hundreds of trillions of amounts of
pieces of token to sell and then you
just create a new token when you're
ready when you run out then a new
Bitcoin plus that has another 17 million
coins and you know ahead of time where
you're going to be at so you never it
never gets out of control because the
dudes can just print another 100
trillion dogecoins and make them all
worth half yeah we're gonna go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and share the show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com click that join us button
for two big reasons one we have our
Discord server set up so when you sign
up there are instructions in the menu
bar for Discord where you can join the
chat hang out with people and we're
going to take calls we're gonna have
people who are in the chat talk and ask
questions for us and the guests and
we'll I think we will be able to do that
today we haven't we haven't uh worked
out the Kinks because the issue is
with a thousand people in the room how
do we pick who gets to be the one person
ask the question or the three people so
what we've built is a way to submit like
hey I want to ask this and then we can
go through like here's a guy who says he
wants to do this
they will try and it's the uncensored so
show so you know who cares we just grab
a random person be like what up ask
something you know what I mean
um but you'll also get access to the
uncensored members only show which will
be live at about 10 10. so uh definitely
check that out and now I'm gonna try and
scroll back that's a good idea with the
with the calls I think that's great
though the idea that you guys came out
that was a great idea
dude yeah that's a great I love that
that's awesome let's I'm gonna start by
reading a regular chat from El Acapulco
he says siren Emoji siren Emoji siren
emotion siren Emoji physical gold and
silver are the only real store of value
and the only escape from the system
only if the system exists because if
there is no system who's gonna buy your
gold or silver what will you do with it
so I often explain it to people very
simply and I've explained it to many of
you who listen if you're it's it's if
the apocalypse happens
let's say like a fungus takes over
people's brains and then you're walking
down the street
and you see a guy with a sandwich and a
guy with some water and you have a bunch
of gold coins do you think either of
them is going to do are going to do
trade with you
or a better way to put it is there's a
guy with a jug of water and you walk up
and say I'm so thirsty please can I have
some water he says no what do you have
to trade you say I have gold he's going
to go and what do I do with gold and
then another guy's gonna walk up and go
I have elk and he's going to say I will
give you some water if you give me some
elk and then they will trade eat and be
merry and you'll be holding heavy metal
that is draining your energy and causing
you to require more food because it's so
damn dense and making you move slowly
and become a Target yeah it's not a
valuable commodity and I mean it's
valuable to the point where they would
take it from you and keep it for later
to sell no only if the system exists but
at an organized place like you're not
going to sell it on the street if if
there is no civilization your gold and
silver are worth nothing it's for like
super conductors you would use it for
like making rings and things out of
there are values to touching certain
metals like they have antibiotic
properties silver does any any sort of
recovery with a civilization though they
would be looking for some form of
currency and that's where it would
actually help for sure unless I'm unless
they go somewhere else and there's value
in something else but when it comes to
like all out destruction no civilization
at all
yeah probably not going to bring you
you'd rather have a rifle with you but
any sort of recovery process or on the
decline I would imagine gold and silver
would actually be quite useful it's
funny because the second chapter of the
book is the scene where the Confederates
are burning down their own capital and
scrambling because they have their money
all they have left is their cabinet and
their money yeah and the city's on fire
so they you know they think they're
going to use the money elsewhere maybe
they burned their own City down there
they burned their own City down because
they didn't want the union to get it but
I thought that was contested no I'm
pretty sure if you if you read a lot of
the Diaries from people back then like
even from William Howard Parker who was
a guy who burnt down his own ship
Confederate oh wow and then went and
helped take the gold too yeah what was
that Ironclad they had what was that
called I don't know the the Confederate
iron club that made us one uh basically
the USS indomitable I believe was that
what it was I think that was the union
and there was another one from the
Confederates I don't know what it was
but that was the first like armed Ship
Battle in History because they both made
Ironclad the roughly the same yeah no
this one this one I think was called the
Patrick Henry and they stole it from the
union and then they burnt it down the
Virginia and there was another one I
watched this documentary about it it was
it was epic yeah but it was funny seeing
not so funny but thinking of that their
civilization is collapsing their literal
Capital has been burnt down right like
where do we do with this money they
didn't have any they kind of aimlessly
traveled south with the money the gold
and the Mexican dollars and uh they're
like Jewels you know and they buried it
well a lot of it disappeared people I
think people pilfered it along the way
desperate soldiers they see their death
of their country the Confederacy and
they
put in their pockets and bounce all
right we're going to read your super
chat so we'll jump to it we've got uh
this one from Adrian Curry she says look
at me I'm important well well all right
okay good working thank you Adrian good
work all right
amazing says imagine if the Democrats
just ignored Trump not easy sure but
wouldn't that send a stronger message
probably not as profitable though you
are correct this is the issue the media
is obsessed with them because he gets
them clicks because the cult is obsessed
with them but the most powerful move
they could do if they wanted to win is
just say nothing about them and never
talk about them yeah they can't help
themselves with that I mean that's why
you know we were talking about this
benefiting Trump largely there's many
ways that it benefits Trump and and even
if that's the consequence they don't
care they want to see him behind bars
and that's all that matters we have the
Super Chat from beef who says that they
have severe stomach pain and they also
have IBS well I'm sorry to hear it beef
I hope you feel better yeah feel better
consult your doctor about what's right
for you to treat your IBS
Goldilocks production says if they
arrest Trump I have a feeling lined
between parties will be solidified and
things will collapse much faster this is
how you break the country apart agreed
yeah seriously and and you got to
consider that too we're looking at the
price of Bitcoin in that whole
conversation based on traditional Market
factors and we need to consider the
second and large large the second and
third largest bank failures happen back
to back within two days and they're
gonna arrest for the first time they're
threatening to a former president those
are things that can destabilize a system
and when bellages like Bitcoin is going
to go up here's the bank stuff I'm also
like you know what else causes
hyperinflation political uncertainty
so if a president if the front runner
for the presidential election 24 gets
arrested and then there's an attempted
indictment and everyone's like I don't
know what's going to happen people are
going to probably flee the dollar
because the US government is what backs
the dollar and if there's no U.S
government then who's back in what yeah
that's that Biden veto concerns me
because the Congress was trying to be
like hey stop investing the US dollar
and woke crap that's not returning an
investment put it in in profitable stuff
and Biden's like nope you're talking
about the videos he said no I don't
think I will yeah no I I don't no I
don't think I will oh God that's I mean
loss of confidence in leadership and the
ability of the dollar if he's really
going to put it into like
you know stopping oil from burning oh my
God that one Gamers as a good candidate
for the culture War podcast would be
Michael Jones of inspiring philosophy
best Christian Channel on YouTube hands
down could be a good debate with him and
Ian
that'd be cool yeah we should we should
do a religion culture War podcast yeah
yeah so the the culture War podcast
Fridays 1pm at youtube.com timcast is we
just started I think we've done what for
four episodes wow look at that I gotta
check that out I haven't I haven't
watched it I saw that you guys did that
it's awesome yeah it's it's less news
driven and more culture conversations
yeah and so we're probably gonna have
musicians I think we actually do have a
couple of musicians ready to come on and
uh what we did we had Pete Parada
already and that's just talking about
issues we're not going to be like
looking at articles like we do on this
show or anything like that we were
talking about the Antichrist the other
night oh man the coming of the second
coming of Christ and and people believe
Donald Trump is the Antichrist I think
it's like an energy like many people
will embody the Antichrist many people
will embody the Christ and it'll kind of
be like within us the battle will be
like what am I am I the anti like truly
look at yourself and your behavior and
kind of got to decide that for yourself
that's deep that's that's a heavy
conversation you're saying people think
Trump is the Antichrist they did the
same thing I haven't seen anyone talking
to people or saying Obama awesome yeah
yeah you got to pay attention to more
liberals man I I um there's who also
believe in Christ I guess no no no no no
just like using the word Antichrist what
you got to understand is that liberals
will come out and be like why are you
doing that acts the Bible says You must
do this and then you're like you're not
even a Christian what are you saying
they're like that doesn't matter so when
they come out and they're like a good
faith argument ever right there sure
when they come out and they're like
Donald Trump is the Antichrist look look
at the prophecy you're like you don't
even believe that stuff like it doesn't
matter as long as it benefits their
agenda they will claim to believe
whatever they have to believe yeah they
get the political points they'll jump to
that argument I love the religious
arguments they make where it's like
dude you're not even religious how is
that an argument you're making to
somebody else when they know you don't
believe it anyway I love the I love like
the Free Speech arguments when they're
like this is unconstitutional you're
like they'll you know try to grandstand
and be this like constitutional
Authority within an argument or
something like that it's like dude you
guys the president like we mentioned
previously like the president launched a
uh what's called
um uh misinformation governance board
a Ministry of Truth yeah and it's like I
don't know why you're lecturing me about
the First Amendment
what all right let's read some more
uh James Eaton says let's say he is
arrested how would that work does a
secret service go to jail with him what
about his food how can he be protected
in public jail
yep could you imagine if Trump I I think
a strong possibility Trump will
surrender Trump wants that photo of
being arrested the same as the left
wants it oh yeah here's the problem yeah
when the left gets the victory they're
done
when the right sees the pro the
persecution of the prosecution they're
enraged that's why it's a stupid move
and these people are like if if the
right really thought arresting Trump
would help them they'd be cheering for
it
if the left is motivated by stopping
Trump and they see a perp walk how many
liberals are going to be like we did it
guys pack it in time to go home Trump's
been arrested how many Trump supporters
are going to say to the streets
so certainly if Trump gets indicted I
imagine he'll be on the first plane and
be like oh woe is me put his hands
behind his back and be like whatever you
say Mr Officer yeah but you need to
protest
something I'm not going to do what if
they rap that'll come out of his mouth
what if he does they bring him to
holding refuse to release him and then
New York New York State just says we
don't care he's not getting out
well they were saying uh they were
actually bringing up no I mean nobody's
serious but Democrats were have been
talking I think like MSNBC they were
talking about maybe a CNN saying no no
bail because of his call to protest
because what he meant by protest wasn't
protest it was violence and a New York
judge who's going to be a far leftists
cult member is going to say you have
already incited Insurrection you are
likely to cause more violence therefore
you are being remanded to the custody of
New York State pending a trial to be
said at a later date or something like
that meanwhile I believe our vice
president or people in her campaign were
donating money to get bailout people
during the riots who are literally
burning down places she tweeted a link
for a bail fund uh that was raising
money from a violent right I believe
they found some bodies in those those uh
burnt down many money months are three
months later if Trump had pulled two
dudes around the back of the house and
shot him in the head I'd be all about
this indictment but he it was some dumb
Finance thing he banged some some porn
star at a party or something like that
and they're like
allegedly yo
um there was this tweet where someone
was like if he committed the crime he
should go to jail and it is it is a it
is violation of the rule of law if they
don't charge him and I was like oh wow
he must be talking about Obama killing
that 16 year old American citizen oh no
he was talking about Trump bribing a
porn star right it's not like this
obvious thing it's this oh that's a
stretch and holy crap you're going for a
felony too this is insane and it's not
just like it's not like this is the
first person that's looked at this
Mueller checked it out yeah southern
district of New York checked it out and
now we have you know what's his face the
D.A
um you know it's it's it's their third
or fourth attempt to get something from
this we got Brendan McGrath music says
shout out to Shane for his great
interview on the Brett Easton Ellis
podcast my two favorite podcasts getting
together for a fascinating discussion
sweet thank you so much for listening to
that that was an honor to be with Brett
one of my favorite favorite authors of
all time yeah yeah that's cool stuff all
right ad look says last week Friday
Selective Service posters were placed
all around the school I work at
reminding boys assigned male at Birth
ages 18 to 25 to register for the draft
because of rising tensions with Russia
and China scary what can you send that a
picture of that do you have a picture of
that
I would like to see that
assigned male at Birth
yeah good luck drafting anybody that way
a signed mail
Steve Smith said why does nobody bring
up the fact that Bill Clinton screwed
his secretary in the White House no she
was an intern
yeah not a secretary Bill Clinton ended
up paying uh what is it 850 000 for
something to kind of go away as well yes
or something yeah he had a situation
that was weird I forgot all the details
like four a lot of those presidents do
yeah bill was
he was sleeping around
fast and loose yeah he'd been hanging
around you know
all right villainous black dragon
entertainment says Tim you were thinking
of bang letting the criminals out from
Dark Knight also do you think dopamine
addiction is connected to Virtue
signaling and why people feel pain when
not woken up yes absolutely but I wasn't
just thinking about Bane The Joker
releasing criminals from Arkham I I
thought that was an old comic book Arc
the bank I think yeah I think that's
actually a really common happening in
the DC Universe yeah it happens
occasionally yeah we'll let out Arkham
because it's a fun well no like the
Joker breaks them all out yeah it
releases all the criminals to wreak
havoc on the city yep yeah
all right
where are we at Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Shane dude I really enjoyed your
the state of modern man opinion piece it
read like a poem The Modern soy boy cult
member is a weak AF thank you
that's one of my favorite pieces is that
what you wrote about no I didn't say
he's a he's a but I did say his
skull is a glory hole and uh it's a
great it's a great article about how I
feel a lot of people
are these days in terms of being weak
men and not defending uh things that I
believe are true and right and worth
defending yeah shout out to uh Chris
Carr and the editors there for putting
up right on
all right let's get some more super jets
okay what is this
the great treasure says Trump is going
to Epstein himself Civil War Tim drink
no I think Trump's not on a rap record
in jail
a rap record yeah like like like shine
when he was in jail just a little call
or a producer and he'll be over the
phone it's gonna be amazing why don't we
just come out with like new tattoos yes
yes
there's so many rappers love him too
I mean I will say that his pardon he did
get Wayne he got oh and Kodak Black so
maybe there's like a sweet uh culturally
that was actually a pretty epic move
right there those were great there was a
lot of more important ones I would have
preferred to totally agree but true
shout out to Little Wayne yeah Dan
Gingrich says the Democrats are
releasing criminals in order to sow
chaos blame their opposition claim they
have the solution to the problem they
caused and then push for more power
agreed the intelligent ones yeah
[Music]
all right
1776's life says speaking about gun
rights tonight might have been violated
by governor pritzker in Illinois I'm
caught in a hard place my family owns a
four generation farm that I would love
to keep working however I know I will
never get my rights back is there a
right move man I don't know
so I'm sorry to hear that yeah what
happened
I'll be curious to know yeah
yeah that's that's unfortunate
brewmaster monk says gabbard Paul for us
all 2024. hmm
that's interesting ticket
Selena says antifa Soros and Schwab
proved they own our democracy what do
you think will happen tomorrow New York
City has already spent more money than
they can find Trump one of the fears we
have is that they're going to pull some
4 AM maneuver
it's going to be way early hours of the
morning when everyone's asleep that way
a bunch of developments can happen
before anybody knows and then you wake
up to a bunch of news that of watching
it happen in real time makes it harder
for people to react really quick to
address the the uh them like owning our
democracy we allow them to by not
controlling the media or any of these
powerful institutions that completely
allow if roles were reversed and there
was these powerful like you know
uh Batman evil villain characters such
as Soros and we dominated the media a
politician wouldn't be able to accept a
dollar from a guy like that so we really
need to get involved in these
institutions to start making an actual
difference so they can't just get away
with this well the problem is people
like Soros then buy the media yeah so
they can control that narrative and make
sure it doesn't happen we have
billionaires too they need to we need to
get to work I mean a billionaire but
it's not about the money orders all the
time it used to buy you access money
that's what it was for but it's really
about the access itself internet video
you have the power to change the world
now with media but I was telling my mom
yesterday and she's like how do you you
even plan to do any of this I was like
internet media yeah the internet video
has changed the entire
media scale the entire surface of the
game is gone there's multiple there's
multiple directions we can go in like or
we you know we as in like Liberty loving
Americans can go in and I think One
Direction certainly is is that route of
going this you know video social media
one a kid a 15 year old can go become a
multi-millionaire media Mogul in like
three years yep by the time they're it's
amazing just one guy owns everything and
they have a tire company serious
cultural influence as well I mean it's a
it's amazing yeah you can say do this 10
000 people do it like that is so
powerful and it's massively dangerous
that's terrifying that's why we got to
keep each other humble but it's the true
power of the nature of the the cult you
know of Personality that it's been
created this is a very important one
from drift motive who says please hit
like everyone that is a very good point
you should hit the like button if you
have not already that is absolutely
correct that's right
decide thought says idea for Discord
server add Channel cultural Endeavors so
we can share our cultural Endeavors with
members addendum separate channel for
meme culture to prevent overloading the
Channel with memes so we are starting
slow I think there's only what like
three channels
three channels because we have like a
moderator and we don't want to get the
thing shut down before anyone has a
chance to do anything substantive so I
think we're planning on doing is
creating a bunch of different rooms you
know for different kinds of creative
work and then the elite club is where
ideally if you want to sign up for that
that's where I'll be hanging out maybe I
don't know if Ian wants to I think Phil
said he'll even like play music and
stuff and other Tim Cask remembers will
be in the elite club and you know the
goal is just to create like look it's a
relatively cheap Social Club Endeavor
because it's not necessarily just about
making money though we do as a business
need to make money to expand but like
the big liberal Social Clubs like in New
York City for instance they're about
four thousand dollars per month
it's crazy it's crazy yeah but hopefully
we get this building set up which is
currently underway and we're gonna have
like a 100 a month West Virginia you
know not to be disrespectful but a lower
income scale because we're not about the
elite New York liver Freedom loving
though you're right yeah and I think
it's awesome a lot of those 4 000 a
month would get you access to a building
with like materials free food free
drinks they do you got but yeah so now
we've got internet video so it's like
cheaper to connect but it's also doesn't
cost as much to join I mean those clubs
are awesome like if you're rich and you
can afford it you show up it's really
nice all the rich people are hanging out
talking to each other this is how they
make money they're friends they Network
there's not that many of them they spend
50 Grand a year to hang out of this club
with free drinks free food and then they
sit at a bar and they they they they
know each other and they'll be like oh
yeah you work in construction right I
got this idea here's what I want to do I
think I'll make a bunch oh that's a good
idea I'll connect you with this guy and
they just networking is so so important
so we got to create something like that
you know that's what we're trying to do
yeah but you got to fund it so the idea
is our space in West Virginia is going
to have like on the third floor food and
drinks but probably more like potato
chips dip
you know sodas and beer with some gaming
tables and it will be only 100 bucks per
month not four thousand you know but the
money is to to pay for someone who's
gonna be working there and honestly
we've talked about it 100 is a great
price but it's probably a loss if we did
it that way but I'm like well we can't
charge more than that because like we're
starting from the bottom we're not
starting from the top
so if we if we you know if we've got to
have someone working there 24 7 or you
know and we've got to have food and
drink stocked 100's probably not it's
probably too low to do it but I'm
willing to subsidize a low price yeah
but we're starting with this Discord
server room and then maybe we can make
something of it yeah I think we've got a
handful of people in there already so I
really do appreciate it people chilling
in the elite chat room yeah man are you
in the Discord we got it pulled up right
here actually so hopefully in the
members only portion of the show that's
awesome some people are mentioning
they're having issues if you're having
issue with the uh Discord just email
members at timcast.com and for the
people who are like damn 100 bucks like
I said the actual liberal Elite clubs
are like four or six thousand dollars a
month and right now it's just the
Discord room but we have the building it
has three floors it exists it's in West
Virginia
um we have to do the construction
what was this oh I was just looking at
the chat IRL live no I was thinking
about the construction the place is
still it's raw I've only seen video of
it at the moment
yeah and we're trying to figure out can
we just open it anyway and then start
off the elite club with a big empty
building and let people turn it into
what they think might work or something
yeah you mentioned that a month a few
weeks ago what was the status on that
it's just permits okay yeah and unless
I'm directly involved and mercilessly
beating the people who are doing it
nothing gets done whips and chains well
whips are too far maybe like a crunching
or something you know retractable baton
but this is what happens you know I'll
say hey this happen I'll go you got it
and then they stopped working on it and
I'm just like okay people are
complaining like hey how come it's not
gonna be done we're made would be
cracked oh that was brutal
all right yeah I don't like saying it I
don't like hearing it I'm a chaos holy
moly all right what do we got
Damien Master says yo Florida doesn't
turn over Trump New York will be forced
to Biden to send feds to get him
interesting Civil War but I don't know
if DeSantis has the walls to actually
defy something like that I mean what are
they going to do if Trump's like I'm not
going but I think Trump will surrender
they said he would and it's the greatest
campaign opportunity for him they don't
understand
it takes the wind out of their sails and
it puts the wind in the sales of the
Trump supporters yep big time
all right
Jazz says Tim fun fact I'm a direct
descendant of the Confederate President
Jefferson Davis wow I bet he's a lot of
descendants at this point right probably
yeah that's one thing I found out while
writing this book maybe other people
know it who know the Civil War better
than me but he had an adopted black
child his wife saw a child a black child
being beaten in the street and she
adopted him oh I felt bad for him he was
with them uh supposedly until the very
end until the union actually captured
Davis did they let him go did they
pardon him and everything no no oh Davis
he yeah he was like oh yeah he was in
jail for a little bit I think he started
writing his book in there uh and then I
believe he was just like oh they
couldn't really get him hmm
they pardoned him was it a pardon I
don't know what they were calling it
then but uh they're trying to get him
for
I forget the words but they they didn't
do it the Meep kid says Robert E Lee was
against slavery but fought for the self
in one of the battles Ulysses S Grant
tried to recruit him wow he's a
fascinating guy Robert E Lee I had a
friend growing up my best friend growing
up loved him and I was always like but
he was for fought for the South that
isn't that evil and he'd be like no no
he fought for his homeland yeah that's
what made him so great yeah well that's
that's a lot of it was it wasn't for a
lot of people in the South it was you
were fighting because the union was
coming and telling you you obey you know
right and they so only I think five
percent of the country actually owned
slaves yeah and it was like you know and
it was bad and they were like wealthier
people who wanted cheap labor yeah one
of the things Grant said after the war
too is that you don't want we don't want
to treat these as the others they're our
fellow countrymen again the country's
United again we're not gonna hold them
responsible or you know put them to
trial or anything like that that's one
of the reasons I think that Davis was he
wasn't generally pardoned by the by the
president but he wasn't taken up I
didn't like get him in trouble basically
I am excited though for when the West
Coast tries to secede Trump sends in the
troops and then California Washington
Oregon enter a period of reconstruction
because they desperately needed that
High-Speed Rail that they've been
talking about you know you can call it
that but reconstruction but basically
what it means is you're going to get rid
of the the corrupt government we're
going to fix the corrupt governments
reconstruction was a failure in the
South too though you know right I'm
joking but they do need it in a lot of
the cities in this country I'm saying
those those places need heavy reform
yeah but you know I just I look forward
to Media Matters writing Tim calls for
violent occupation of west coast states
oh yeah shout out to those people great
articles written if you've got friends
over there too yeah they love me yeah
yeah
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says dang
it in you ain't lying saying ish will
happen three plus years back in 2020 and
now today the circle connects I'm
rooting for not the fall Bud interesting
no I did see the inflation on year three
of IRL March 2020 is when that inflation
crap when I came into the room and I was
like dude inflation's gonna go nuts
because they just printed a bunch of
money there was that coveted package
yeah and then it was like eight months
10 months 15 months later you start to
see it yeah
and we bought all that crypto we were
both like
this is happening and everything
went up up yeah what the bite
Administration is doing right now
they're comparing you know they're
saying like oh we've cut spending and
they're just comparing their spending to
the highest dollar amount in 2020. it's
like dude come on you're still like way
above 2019. yeah otm marketing podcast
says if you click join Discord in the
embedded Link at the bottom of the page
that link works top link does not work
interesting
all right let's grab one more Brian
Taylor says start coordinating the
purchase of stock on the institution
buying material positions in the
institution stock and become activist
I don't I think there may be typos there
cleaning house with the board oh I think
he's saying buy stocks in these
companies so that you can vote and then
fix these companies all right if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and become a member at
timcast.com go to timcast.com then click
join us in the menu bar
sign up and we will have a members only
live uncensored coming up for you in
about 10 minutes and if you are signed
into the Discord we will make an attempt
into pulling in someone for a a call-in
I don't know exactly how we can do it
maybe we'll just grab a few people who
want to and put them in a voice Channel
and then turn the voice channel on and
see if that works it's awesome sounds
great yeah yeah because we were like how
do you ask a thousand people who wants
to be the person asked the question yeah
for the for the for the show or whatever
but uh yeah go for it it's gonna be fun
and uh you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
uh James you want to shout anything out
yeah yeah uh subscribe to my YouTube
channel youtube.com James klug you can
also catch me on Twitter real James
cluge you guys thank you thank you for
having me absolutely awesome I am at
Shane Cashman on Twitter Instagram uh
I'm asking you to please go purchase
this book I'm very I've never been more
proud of a book it's it's huge uh the
paperback is available right now at
ghost of the Civil war.com and the the
ebook will be available at midnight uh
shout out to Jessica Boone for doing
this amazing cover yeah shout out to
Chris Carr for being the editor uh shout
out to Tim for sending me to Washington
Georgia where my life was turned upside
down every time I went there oh a shout
out to Clint Brantley who's the family
who brought me down there first place
but uh I love this book I'm very proud
of it uh and I hope you guys enjoy it
I'm happy to finally have it out and uh
how many pages is it it's 473 Pages holy
crap tell me that URL again where people
buy that it is Ghost of the Civil
war.com ghost of the Civil war.com yeah
ghost was bought up so we were like
singular so we just yeah but uh it's
there the paperback is available right
now ebook tonight I've been saying this
I feel like this is the kind of stuff
these stories are exactly up Joe Rogan's
alley yeah you know it'd be great to
talk to him I mean well this this book
it just it encompasses everything it's
funny talking today with about like the
banks failing the money the country
collapsing uh the president's uh not
being trusted violence it's it's like a
reflection of you know the Civil War and
we just keep going through this madness
you know word so it's a happy book it's
okay good it's a white pill but not
oxycodone thank you thank you very much
good to see you James and also I want to
make clarification do coins based off a
Litecoin and it actually has apparently
has its own blockchain I thought it was
on the binance blockchain it is when you
go to metamask but there there you go
I'm Ian Crossland I'm really looking
forward to talking to you guys at the
Discord on the after show let's see how
this technology goes yep and uh I am at
sir.com please argue with me on Twitter
uh I had some music that uh dropped on
Friday I wasn't on the show Kellen was
doing the podcast
um if you want to check that out it's on
cool contest records please if you like
dance music go for it thank you oh you
know what else we have a song coming out
on Friday I'm supposed to promote it
hell yeah promotion right up maybe yeah
maybe I should say that yeah please do
yeah it's good it's the first one we
recorded but we held it until it's
coming out four no second one record
because you did will people the first
well yeah that was a while ago without
Carter before Carter the first one with
Carter yeah yeah and it's we've been
sitting on it for about a year
so I love it I think this song's great I
hope I hope the audience likes it as
much as I do I really enjoy it I like
the harmonies there's three of us was it
me you Carter and Carter singing on it
and the uh there's a clip I posted on my
Instagram of just like a quick little
snippet where you can pre-order but
we'll get the links and everything set
up for tomorrow so it's easier for me to
tell you where to get it but otherwise
I'll just be at youtube.com I think Tim
cast songs I think the channel is now
trash House Records we'll figure it out
I don't know it's gonna be fun we found
a music video so anyway uh thanks for
hanging out everybody head over to
timcast.com and we'll have that members
only uncensored live in a few minutes
we'll see you there